bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver cet après midi sur public
sénat pour le moment fort du jour au
sénat les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
à 15 heures les sénateurs vont
interroger les ministres sur les sujets
du jour du moment et on va vous faire
vivre tous ses échanges avec notre
équipe est dans notre équipe il ya
d'abord le commentateur idéalement placé
en tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat quentin calmet bonjour aujourd'hui
est bien un sujet fait la une
aujourd'hui alex avec pas moins de six
questions consacré au gel et qui
inquiète et bien les viticulteurs et
aussi les arboriculteurs
cela a touché beaucoup de départements
et donc cela mobilise beaucoup les
sénateurs aujourd'hui
merci quentin et puis nous irons voir
notre interviewer politique en salle des
conférences du sénat pour recueillir
toutes les réactions des ministres des
sénateurs bonjour steve bonjour alex
alors qu'ils auraient vous à votre micro
aujourd'hui il ya un élu inquiet
extrêmement remontés contre la décision
du gouvernement de reporter d'une
semaine des élections régionales et
départementales prévues au mois de juin
salle telus et philippe bas sénateurs l
ère de la manche et sera mon micro dans
quelques instants
et nous irons voir également notre
streamer politique jean massiet qui va
suivre cette séance de questions
d'actualité sur la plateforme switch
avec tout s'accumule sa communauté dans
le cadre de l'émission sénat stream
salut genre salut alex et oui on a hâte
de voir les questions posées par les
sénateurs cet après midi notamment le
variant brésilien qui commence à
inquiéter et on va en parler de ce
variant brésilien à 14h30 puisque et
bien hier le premier ministre jean
castex a annoncé la suspension des vols
entre le brésil et la france et ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face entre le
sénateur centriste d'un côté olivier
cadic qui est plutôt partisan d'une
liberté de circulation et de l'autre le
sénateur les républicains du vaucluse
alain milon qui lui veut des mesures
sanitaires plutôt strict ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face
mais d'abord on va parler du sujet du
jour au sénat le maintien des élections
régionales et départementales au mois de
juin avec un report d'une semaine alors
une question se pose comment organiser
ce scrutin en plein troisième vague de
la pandémie
pour en parler à chaque oeil sur ce
plateau laure darcos sénatrice l'est
républicain de l'essonne est d'ailleurs
joué en 10 dates aux élections
départementales
bonjour non geo j'accueille également
prisca thévenot porte parole de la
république en marche
bonjour bonjour et puis nous serons à
distance avec jean daniel lévy directeur
délégué d'harris interactive bonjour
bonjour est également christophe
bouillon le président de l'association
des petites villes de france
bonjour bonjour alors on va revenir
d'abord sur les annonces qui ont été
faites hier par jean castex à
l'assemblée nationale lors d'un débat
sur ces élections régionales et
départementales
le même débat aura lieu cet après midi
au sénat on fait le point avec pierre
henri holderbaum après avoir lancé une
consultation des maires le gouvernement
maintient les élections régionales et
départementales avec un report d'une
semaine passant des dimanches 13 et 20
juin au 20 et 27 juin
certes ce n'est qu'une semaine mais une
semaine supplémentaire
une semaine de vaccination un plus
soit au moins deux millions de personnes
vaccinées
ce maintien des élections satisfait le
groupe majoritaire du sénat le premier
ministre un délai d'une semaine
supplémentaire
il justifie sa part le fait qu' on aura
une meilleure situation sanitaire bon
personne n'est dupe c'est aussi pour
sauver la face à monsieur ferrand qui
lui avaient demandé un report mais nous
l'essentiel étant de maintien des
élections choix pour prendre une
respiration démocratique que soit le 13
ou 20 fois pour nous l'essentiel c'était
le maintien de ces élections pour
maintenir les élections jean castex a
détaillé un protocole pour la campagne
des candidats les outils dématérialisés
sont encouragés comme un site internet
recensant leurs professions de foi
avant chacun des deux tours les débats
seront diffusés à la télé et à la radio
pour les jours des votes le premier
ministre a annoncé l'extension des
horaires de bureau de 8h à 20h et chacun
des électeurs pourra disposer de deux
procurations pour le sénateur socialiste
il n'y a pas de nouveauté dans ces
mesures leur teint volontaires qui a été
pris par le gouvernement de mettre en
place des mesures un peu plus
caractérisée par l'innovation comme le
vote par correspondance ou l'heureux par
anticipation
on redonne vie au goût du jour à des
choses qui existent qui existe déjà mais
c'est la seule chose qu'on puisse faire
dans des délais aussi brefs
alors que dans le même temps on a eu un
an pour s'adapter et que des pays
d'autres pays occidentaux l'ont fait eux
en cours - tant du côté des bureaux de
vote les membres pourront se faire
vacciner et testé obligatoirement 48
heures avant le scrutin
pour éviter une trop grande
concentration de personnes les
dépouillements pourront se tenir à
l'extérieur
alors on va analyser toutes les
questions que pose cette organisation à
des élections régionales et
départementales
d'abord laure darcos est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite par le maintien de ces
élections en juin avec le report d'une
semaine alors le maintien des élections
oui bien évidemment
on a tous été un petit peu choqué
vraiment ébranlé par la conseillère de
consultation des maires du week-end
dernier on va parler non pas que les
consultations ne devait pas avoir lieu
mais à partir du moment où les grandes
assemblées comme la mmf l'adf avait déjà
donné leur point de vue et qui forcément
avec consulter leur base
on avait trouvé que c'était vraiment un
dernier recours pour essayer de faire
basculer le le le
l'autre cas le fait de reporter à
nouveau les élections là où je voudrais
pas me dire à vos auditeurs qui nous
écoutent
parce que j'ai eu moi sur les réseaux
sociaux quand j'ai relayé le fait qu'il
fallait absolument que ça se
maintiennent en juin j'aurai pourra leur
dire que parce que souvent certains
m'ont dit mais c'est un taux de
politiciens entre vous nous on en a rien
à faire ce qu'on veut c'est être
vaccinés pouvoir revivre normalement
mais en fait ça change leur quotidien
faisant partie d'un exécutif au conseil
départemental de l'essonne je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui nos oppositions nous
empêche entre guillemets de voter des
nouveaux budgets des nouveaux projets et
donc si on avait reporté à nouveau les
élections c'est aussi un report par
exemple de décisions d'une construction
d'un nouveau collège pareil pour les
régions et qu'au fond c'est l'ensemble
du quotidien des français qui en
auraient été en fait un pacte est comme
ça avait été le cas au moment des
municipales souvenez-vous puisque du
coup des décisions et des budgets
n'avait pas être pu être votée en temps
et en heure à cause du report du
deuxième tour donc ce que je voulais
dire c'est que c'est pas un bidouillage
de politique entre eux c'est la
démocratie qui doit en tout cas
continuer à vivre donc bien évidemment
je me réjouis de ce maintien
je regrette juste c'est pareil on
n'avait pas fait pour embêter le
gouvernement si l'on avait maintenu les
13 et 20 juin
c'est que 27 c'est le départ des
vacances et que ça ne serait pas bon non
plus pour la démocratie d'avoir trop de
d'abstention
ni pour ceux qui seront élus ni pour
ceux qui se seront présentées je pense
que c'est pas très sain et ça ça me fait
craindre le pire
voilà presque a été mené on entend les
arguments de laure darcos et finalement
c'est lié à toute la pression que les
responsables politiques d'opposition ont
mis sur le gouvernement pour ne pas
reporter ces élections les maintenir en
jouant est ce que le gouvernement avait
vraiment le choix la boussole ça a
échappé à personne depuis maintenant
plus d'un an malheureusement la boussole
est la crise sanitaire
donc le premier enjeu est celui là
effectivement
l'enjeu c'est de maintenir l'exercice
démocratique pleinement tout en
respectant et en veillant à la sécurité
sanitaire de tous aussi bien des
électeurs mais également des élus qui
organise ces élections et aussi de ceux
qui font que cette élection et permet
permise les scrutateurs et dépouilleurs
etc
donc je pense qu'il ne s'agit pas d'être
dans un jeu démocratique comme vous le
disait de simple opposition mais de
s'assurer que tous puissent bien se
faire parce que ces élections
effectivement on en parle très peu mais
ce sont des élections est extrêmement
importante pour la vie de chacun au
quotidien
et quelque part j'ai envie de dire et si
finalement tout ce sujet tous eu un peu
de tapage autour de ça permettait à
chacun de s'intéresser à ces élections
qui sont fondamentales qui sont
extrêmement fondamental
donc je pense que le plus important
c'est que tout le monde ait pu donner
son avis j'entends tout à fait le sujet
du les associations ont été consultés et
finalement les maires on leur a aussi
demandé leur avis je pense que c'est
important notamment dans le fait que sur
l'ensemble des ces mères qui ont été
sont consultés 69% vraiment 69 % ont
répondu
donc il y avait aussi besoin de
s'exprimer parce que finalement c'est
eux qui vont être en première ligne
demain pour organiser cela je devrais
juste pour répondre à cela parce que
nous là aussi on a été un petit peu
choqué parce qu'on a utilisé le système
gala qu'ils savaient qui est un système
informatique qui est en général utilisé
dans les préfectures au moment des crues
et donc on a utilisé ce système là pour
relancer l'ensemble des maires nous on a
eu des maires qui ont été sollicités par
les sous-préfets jusqu'à 11h45 pour
qu'il réponde je suis d'accord avec vous
moi je trouve que c'est important de
toute façon qui s'exprime dans un sens
ou dans l'autre parce qu'ils sont en
première ligne
j'ai eu en effet des mères qui m'ont dit
comment on va faire comment on va gérer
ses bureaux nous avec vincent delahaye
mon collègue centriste sénateurs nous
avons deux
d envoyer une lettre au premier ministre
cosigné de beaucoup de nos collègues
pour que en tout cas les assesseurs et
ceux qui tiendront les bureaux soient
prioritaires s'ils doivent en parler on
va donner la parole à christophe
bouillon qui représente les petites
villes de france car maintenant que la
décision est plutôt prises dans ces
élections vont avoir lieu fin juin
et bien la responsabilité a reposé sur
les élus des communes qui vont devoir
organiser ce scrutin
oui les élus s'affairent vous savez
depuis plus d'un an
à chaque fois que dans le cas de la
crise sanitaire on a fait appel aux
maires des plus largement aux élus ils
ont su répondre présent même si bien
évidemment ils font le constat que
l'organisation de ces élections n'est
pas une simple affaire d'abord parce
qu'il ya deux scrutins en même temps on
parle beaucoup d'ailleurs de les
élections régionales mais n'oublions
jamais les élections départementales et
le fait d'avoir en commun ces deux
élections complique on imagine
l'occupation des bureaux de vote
l'organisation en circulation dans les
espaces de la même façon le recrutement
entre guillemets les assesseurs l'est
pas non plus il va faire ça quoi qu'il
en soit en tant qu'association et parmi
toutes les associations on avait répondu
à la question du gouvernement bien avant
que les mères dans leur ensemble soit
sollicité pas simplement pour dire oui
ou non
mais pour faire des propositions et il
faut pas l'oublier que on avait demandé
par exemple un élargissement de l'anc
étude des horaires de pouvoir voter
le fait de mutualiser les bureaux entre
les deux élections
le fait aussi de pouvoir à l'extérieur
procédé à quelques opérations notamment
pourquoi pas celle qui consiste au
dépouillement
mais on souhaitait aussi que soient
prises en considération au delà du
moment du vote du jour du vote
la question de la campagne parce que
forcément respectée que les candidats ne
sont pas placés à égalité dans cette
campagne
puisqu'on peut quasiment voir personne
c'est la raison pour laquelle on avait
demandé non seulement avoir accès à des
médias publics
on parle de débat oui c'est une bonne
chose mais souvent on considère
uniquement les régions il faut quand
même que les départementales notamment
les cantons puissent être concernés et
ont souhaité on a été entendu
que les candidats puissent bénéficier
d'une attestation en tout cas une
possibilité déplacement pour faire pour
faire campagne
justement le sujet va être travaillée
par le gouvernement cette attestation de
déplacement des candidats je voudrais
qu'on parle du calendrier avec juste une
dernière question sur le calendrier à
jean daniel lévy on reporte ces
élections sur un week-end de départ en
vacances est ce que ça peut encore
aggravée l'abstention qui pourrait être
très élevé sur ce scrutin mais ça peut
aggraver l'abstention de ceux qui n'ont
pas forcément l'intention d'aller voter
ou dessus qui ne sont pas persuadés que
leur vote va être utile d'une manière
générale on voit bien que lorsqu'il ya
des aspects qui apparaissent comme étant
absolument essentiel lorsqu'on jeudi que
voter est un devoir civique lorsqu'on
pense qu'il ya un enjeu à se déplacer
pour aller voter là ce qu'on pense que
les politiques publiques qui sont à
déployer au sein du département ou au
sein de la région diffère selon qu'on
ait un candidat un deux ou trois qui
sera à la tête de l'institution
on est prêts localement à pouvoir
différer son départ en vacances c'est
aussi ça évidemment était prévue depuis
très longtemps
ce qui n'est pas encore le cas donc
qu'on attende anciennement aujourd'hui
on le voit une baisse de la
participation électorale et que dans des
périodes qui ce n'est pas l'intention
sanitaire que cette participation
électorale était relativement faible
on a l'exemple parfait qui s'est
déroulée non seulement au cours des
dernières élections municipales mais
également au cours des élections
partielles qui se sont déroulées depuis
lors dans qu on peut penser que le fait
que étaient les élections se déroulent
dans le cadre d'un départ potentiel en
vacances ne changera pas
fondamentalement les choses là ce qui se
passe à l'heure actuelle c'est qu'on
parle ici est effectivement été un jeu
électoraux qu'on parle des prochaines
élections mais que l'immense majorité
des français n'est absolument pas
confronté aujourd'hui à ce que sont les
débats des élections régionales où des
élections départementales
il ya peu de l'affiché qui sont
présentes sur les murs il ya peu de
tractage qui sont effectués il ya une
campagne télévisuelle ou audiovisuelle
qui apparaît comme étant relativement
faible
et puis même dé manière générale dans
les médias il y a une page extrêmement
importante qui encore est accordée à la
commune et pas forcément aux gros enjeux
de ce que peuvent être les boutiques
régionales et départementales voir les
gens découvrent et jean daniel lévy
justement on va en parler de cette
campagne électorale comment faire
campagne en plein troisième vague de
l'épidémie avant de vous donner la
parole on va aller en salle des
conférences du sénat retrouver steve
jourdain qui est avec la sénatrice
communiste cécile que karman qui
d'ailleurs est tête de liste aux
élections régionales en auvergne
rhône-alpes louis cécile kerman
sénatrice communiste et tête de liste
donc en région auvergne rhône-alpes
je m'adresse à la candidate très
concrètement comment vous faites
campagne en ce moment j'imagine que
c'est pas simple non écoutés bon d'avoir
ce qui n'est pas simple ça aide quand on
est apte à l'échelle de ces grandes
régions nous l'avons déjà connu à
travers la campagne de 2015
douze départements donc de il ya déjà
ces contraintes la et puis il ya une
évitables le mans ce besoin de s'adapter
de respecter les consignes sanitaires et
donc de multiplier les déplacements de
multiplier les rencontres pour que à
chaque fois celle ci se fasse en plus
petit comité puisque nous reconnaître en
tant traditionnels justement j'ai vu que
vous organisiez des déplacements
numérique qu'est ce qu'un déplacement
numérique très concrètement écouter la
semaine dernière c'était à la fois des
candidats qui sont physiquement présents
et puis la possibilité tout de même de
suivre par
retransmission les différents
déplacements et en tout cas pouvoir
continuer cette interaction
indispensable entre des réalités vécues
sur le terrain la rencontre des
candidats et les échanges avec nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens j'imagine
que ne pas rencontrer ne pas être au
contact de la population c'est pas
forcément toujours simple à ce que ce
scrutin est en quelque sorte biaisé
davance bah écoutez je crois que ça
c'est ce sont les semaines à venir nous
ne pouvons qu espérer que la situation
aucune âme sanitaire s'améliore et que
ce contact puis se renforcer mais je
veux le redire à l'heure actuelle il y à
des rencontres il ya des échanges
il y à des déplacements en excite
habituellement dans des entreprises dans
les lieux de culture qui sont fermés
pour lequel beaucoup se mobilisent sur
les exploitations agricoles rencontrer
des entreprises innovantes
donc je crois que cela se continue le
plus frustrant peut-être aujourd'hui
surtout dans une élection régionale vous
savez où sur ma liste il y aura deux
cent trente candidats c'est plus aussi
l'incapacité à faire ensemble et en
dynamique collective et finalement de
devoir beaucoup plus séquencée et isoler
les différentes rencontres sur vue il
n'y aura pas de prime au sortant
mais écoutez d'abord je crois que chaque
élection il ya des prime au sortant il
est ce que d'avoir la crise sanitaire ou
pas pour qu'il y ait des prime aux
sortants c'est moi je ne fais pas partie
de ceux qui disent que les élections
sont joués d'avancé je crois que comme à
chaque élection il ya des surprises il y
à des confirmations et face sont les
électeurs dodin grenade qui le
décideront en juin prochain
petite dernière question vous redoutez
pas une abstention massive à ces
élections ci mais vous savez il y a deux
ans nous aurions pu déjà échangé
malheureusement scrutin après scrutin en
notre pays l'abstention augmente
l'abstention explose et donc la crise
politique
aujourd'hui ne peut être résumée
simplement une crise sanitaire donc nous
avons alerté depuis maintenant plusieurs
années il y as besoin de repenser
compris la relation entre les élus les
candidats la population pour rassembler
et effectivement réduire cette
abstention
mais ce n'est pas simplement lié à la
crise sanitaire fait aussi lié aux
paroles rassurantes que tiendront
ou pas les ministres le gouvernement
parce que bien évidemment si à la veille
d'un scrutin
on annonce la fermeture des bars et les
restaurants comme avons connu à la
veille du 15 mars dernier
cela n'incite pas non plus les
électrices et les électeurs à aller
voter
merci beaucoup merci c'est il tue qui
emmène d'abord là pour dire à mes
questions merci beaucoup steve on a
entendu les difficultés de faire
campagne posée par cécile que karman je
voudrais juste qu'on écoute et bien ce
qu'en pense richard ferrand le président
l'assemblée nationale qui est favorable
à un report du scrutin en octobre et
pour lui cette campagne est tout
simplement impossible il prend un
exemple concret on écoute je vous
prendre un exemple en bretagne on ami
thierry burlot qui avait affrété un
autocar pour pouvoir aller sillonner la
bretagne pour être à l'écouté des
bretonnes et des bretons pour pouvoir
dire ces propositions etc
il a dû remiser pour tout le mois
d'avril son autobus au garage il un papy
ne peut pas faire campagne là où
al'inverse les sortants je vous rappelle
qu'ils exercent eiic en organiser les
pays bas le portugal et sortants eux
sont au travail et naturellement se font
valoir ce qui est normal je ne leur fais
aucun reproche mais cela crée c'est son
prénom lui était en fait les mêmes
choses oui d'inéquitable presqu'à
thévenot entendu richard ferrand une
campagne sur le terrain faut faire une
croix dessus non il faut pas faire une
croix dessus mais elle va être forcément
différente et j'ai envie de dire sans
être dans un langage de bisounours ou
d'excès positivité mais peut-être que ça
va nous obliger tous et toutes
et je parle de manière transparente izan
à nous réinventer sur le principe de la
participation démocratique parce
qu'effectivement il rejoint ce que vous
venez de dire madame la sénatrice juste
avant l'enjeu ici c'est de faire en
sorte que le maximum de personnes
puissent elles aux ions dans des
conditions sanitaires absolument
sécurisées et l'enjeu c'est le taux de
participation est en dehors même de la
crise sanitaire sept ans je reste là est
toujours là donc quelque part il va
falloir se réinventer je ne doute pas
que ça pourra être fait et le sujet de
la prime aux sortants ta prime au
sortant
elle est là de toute façon que ce soit
en crise sanitaire pas en crise
sanitaire à nous justement d'aller
encore plus et toujours plus aller
débattre sur le fond des idées sur le
fond des projets à un moment même où les
français en ont besoin
et justement peut-être un calendrier où
on pourra enfin peut-être respirer un
peu plus et se dire quel est le monde
d'après que nous voulons avec qui
comment et peut-être que ça va peut être
engagée
plus de vote pour ces élections laure
darcos à vous êtes candidate aux
élections départementales dans l'essonne
comment vous allez réinventer la
campagne électorale c'est très frustrant
moi je suis d'accord avec accessible que
je trouve très très allantes très
positive mais moi j'ai l'habitude de
faire beaucoup de porte à porte beaucoup
de réunions publiques beaucoup de 2,2 de
tractage sur les marchés c'est ce que
c'est ce que j'ai toujours aimé moi dans
la vie militante
et en effet il va falloir se réinventer
alors on joue avec mon binôme on
commence déjà à travailler sur notre
document je pense que les documents
écrits vont être du coup
particulièrement attendu puisque les
gens sont chez eux ils vont avoir plus
le temps à la limite de lire un joli
document avec alors les projets bien
évidemment le bilan pour les sortants
al'inverse de ce que dit monsieur
ferrand l'opposition je peux vous
assurer dans les instances marque aussi
parce qu'on a quand même en sièges
encore actuellement marque aussi leurs
différences et font campagne d'une
certaine manière en rentrant beaucoup
plus énergiquement dans dans les élus
dans les élus de la majorité que qu'ils
ne le font habituellement donc la
campagne elle est là mais c'est vrai que
c'est très frustrant et là où je trouve
qu'il ya eu bien sûr des avancées
annoncées par mathieu castex mais ce que
je regrette par exemple c'est que le
gouvernement n'ait pas retenu une
proposition qui avait fait fait liban
dans sa proposition qui était par
exemple de pouvoir permettre aux gens
qui vraiment sont et théo tétanisés à
l'idée de sortir de chez eux de ne pas
pouvoir avoir le droit de d'avoir un au
pays qui viennent chez eux pour leur
procuration pour l'instant seules les
personnes en vraie difficulté de maladie
ou autre
on le droit mais nous on avait vraiment
été beaucoup plus loin en disant si
vraiment la personne ne se veut pas
sortir beauté qu'on puisse avoir aussi
sa procuration alors deux procurations
par personne on va s'employer bien
évidemment à ce qu' on puisse en effet
faire parler ce qui nous n'irons pas
voter
mais honnêtement c'est quand même un peu
frustrant de ne pas pouvoir le faire
et puis je rajoute une chose on sait
très bien que ce sont souvent les
personnes les seniors qui vote
massivement puisque les jeunes c'est
d'ailleurs souvent regrettable et et
honnêtement par visioconférence c'est
souvent très difficile pour eux donc moi
je veux bien tout ce qu'on veut de se
réinventer
mais on sait très bien qu'on va avoir un
manque de dialogue est vraiment des
changes avec ces personnes là qui en
général votre vraiment massivement
pendant cette campagne donc bien sûr
qu'elle va être fruste rentrer c'est
évident mais oui une campagne qui
s'orientent plutôt sur le numérique sur
les réseaux sociaux jean daniel lévy est
ce que ça peut exclure de ce scrutin les
seniors oui forcément on comprend en
tout cas à ce niveau là on sait que ce
sont des moins adepte de l'utilisation
des réseaux sociaux que ce sont les
moins adepte actuellement notamment
parmi les personnes qui sont âgés de 75
ans et plus de l'utilisation d'internet
d'un point de vue global et qui même en
termes de communication sont beaucoup
plus sensibles avec une communication
papier ou une communication
traditionnels en face à face que à
travers une communication
je serais tenté de dire plus digital
consorts
alors je me souvins leur perception de
la campagne dans un mélange quand on
regarde aujourd'hui les personnes qui
sont des personnages et ce sont celles
qui prennent le plus de temps pour quoi
se forger leur avis ce sont celles qui
sont le plus enclines à prendre leur
décision bien en amour il pas forcément
au cours des derniers jours où dès la
semaine qui précède de spray temps parce
qu'elles sont plus informés que les
autres sur ce que peuvent être le rôle
des différentes institutions le rôle des
différents acteurs et donc les moins
sujet à des mobilisations électorale de
diana minutes ou à des changements
d'opinion ou de comportements électoraux
dès la minute christophe bouillon aussi
cette campagne est un peu détournée
de l'électorat senior est ce que ça peut
créer une inéquité démocratique oui oui
clairement on voit qu'il ya une
différence qui s'établit déjà entre les
sortants et les postulants le sortant
peut valoriser en effet son travail
continue à participer à des
manifestations officielles qu'il
soutient souvent de sa collectivité en
terme de communication d'ikea à risque
de rupture d'égalité de ce point de vue
là il faut comme le disait la vie elle
instaure aussi que les médias parlent
plus souvent possible de ce qui se passe
dans les régions et départements
rappelle les compétences je dis bien
régions et départements
parce que souvent on entend parler
uniquement les régionales et très peu
des départementales ce qui est un peu
dommage parce qu'il ya des compétences
essentielles et notamment des
compétences qui sont essentiels pour les
âges et pour les seniors
je souhaite aussi est ce qu'on regarde
la question des moyens offerts campagne
vous l'avez dit ce sont sans doute des
moyens numériques de la communication
papier pourquoi pas des courriers ciblés
et qu'ils vont être plutôt considérer
que d'autres moyens habituels de prise
de contact simplement le niveau de
dépenses autorisé reste assez faible
vous savez si vous souhaitez tout
simplement envoyé un courrier à
l'ensemble des habitants de notre
territoire
eh bien ça risque de consommer
l'ensemble de l' enveloppe que vous ne
vous disposez je pense qu'il faut aussi
permettre malgré tout à ce que les
candidats en respectant bien évidemment
des consignes sanitaires puissent se
déplacer plus facilement
on pourrait imaginer par exemple pour
reprendre l'exemple cité tout à l'heure
par le président de l'assemblée
nationale que des candidats puissent
circuler de village aux communes de
village en village de communes aux
communes pour se retrouver sur les
places du marché sur les places de
centres bourgs ou place de mairie pour
essayer malgré tout de maintenir un
filet de contact avec les électeurs
mais on a à peine 70 jours de campagne
je pense qu'en la matière il faut que
vous m la démultipliée comme le dit dans
ce domaine sportif pour permettre à tous
les candidats de faire campagne
mais le faire de façon équitable ce qui
n'est pas encore le cas aujourd'hui
oui cette campagne va aller très vite on
va rapidement se diriger vers le
du scrutin une question se pose comment
sécuriser au niveau sanitaire
le premier tour et le second tour de ces
élections régionales départementales et
territoriales faut le préciser notamment
pour nos téléspectateurs par exemple de
corse ou de guyane alors sur la sécurité
sanitaire de ce scrutin
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex
hier à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
qu'il préconise est bien en suivant les
conseils les préconisations du conseil
scientifique
voilà sur ce qu'il préconise pour
protéger les membres des bureaux de vote
le conseil scientifique recommande par
ailleurs la vaccination ou à défaut le
dépistage de l'ensemble des membres des
bureaux de vote
pour ceux qui n'auraient pu encore
bénéficier de la vaccination le
gouvernement mettra en place un
dispositif particulier trois semaines
avant le premier tour les communes
seront invités à faire connaître la vis
des personnes non vaccinées membres des
bureaux de vote et fonctionnaires
mobilisés le jour du scrutin afin qu'une
vaccination puisse leur être proposées
le conseil scientifique prévoit par
ailleurs qu' à défaut de vaccins
les membres des bureaux de vote devront
réaliser un test
il pourra s'agir d'un test pcr ou d'un
test antigénique réalisés dans les 48
heures précédentes
laure darcos au vu de la campagne
vaccinale française qui connaît quand
même des soubresauts est ce que vous
pensez donc on peut sérieusement
vacciner tous les membres des bureaux de
vote d'ici le mois de juin bon alors
déjà ça serait ceux qui sont volontaires
un pin évidemment parce que j'ai une
petite critique là dessus en grande
comme six jeux on voulait imposer en
fait à la vaccination
je pense que ça va être compliqué parce
que d'abord j'espère en effet comptera
30 millions de personnes à fin juin ça
veut dire que du coup à mi juin
on en aura en tout cas plus de plus de
20 25
on sait en plus par ailleurs que ce
hôpitaux de personnes âgées aussi qui
tiennent les bureaux 1 les jeunes
souvent se mobilise pas assez donc
j'espère que cela soit en majorité déjà
protégée par par le vaccin
mais là où vous avez raison c'est que
même pot je pensais aux scrutateurs
parce qu'on parle de ceux qui tiennent
les bureaux et savoir en effet s'il va y
avoir ou pas dédoublement parce qu'il ya
de scrutin mais les scrutateurs le soir
est ce que il faudra vous savez très
bien que c'est versatile les gens
se décident au dernier moment s'ils vont
pas rester pour dépouiller les bulletins
savoir comment on va faire pour vraiment
être sûr qu'ils soient négatifs et qu'
ils ne vont pas risquer de propager le
virus
donc tout ça est très peu très compliqué
moi je voulais demander à notre mère si
par exemple je sais que dans les écoles
ça va être aussi difficile puisque
heureusement le 30 ans sera la fin des
vacances enfin juste avant les vacances
mais est ce qu'on peut en effet avoir la
possibilité de le faire à l'extérieur
s'il fait pas trop mauvais mais bon les
bulletins peuvent s'envoler donc c'est
un peu compliqué est ce que ça peut être
dans des dans des salles d'associations
ou des idées ou des gymnases j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas je pense qu'il
faudra qu'on aide en effet tous nos
mères pour mettre en place dans un
espace le plus rationnelle possible avec
le circulation la plus rationnelle
possible pour que ces lieux dans les
bonnes conditions mais c'est vrai que on
va devoir tous retrousser les manches
pour aider nos élus à mettre en place et
ses bureaux de vote c'est d'ailleurs le
gouvernement envisage de rendre possible
un dépouillement en plein air à
christophe bouillon c'est une bonne
solution d'ailleurs vous l'avait proposé
oui en effet on a proposé qu'on puisse
pourquoi pas est quasiment le dessiner
la veille pour des questions évidentes
de météo de se retrouver notamment dans
l'est vous savez il ya des prêts ou dans
les grandes écoles mais beaucoup de
bureaux de vote concrètement de les
communes qui se passe dans les écoles
traditionnellement on pourrait imaginer
ou puissants les faits de façon très
pratique se retrouver à l'extérieur ne
serait ce que pour les opérations de
dépouillement qui sont toujours des
opérations où il ya des attroupements en
tout cas une possibilité qui est plus
tout le monde que lorsqu'on est revenue
en terme de circulation et je rejoins ce
que vient de dire notre collègue
sénatrice c'est que fenaux confiance
aussi à réalisation des mers et
croyez-moi de figure mais nous sommes
déjà à la manoeuvre ne serait ce que
pour recruter ses soeurs ne serait-ce
que avec leurs services pour regarder
comment organiser les choses très
concrètement en terme de circulation
n'oublions jamais que
au moment des municipales déjà nous
avions été au rendez vous des conditions
certes différents mais malgré tout tout
ce qui concerne la sécurité sanitaire
les affectations des lieux la
disposition j'ai les masques etc
on sait faire après sur la question de
la vaccination
on était favorable plutôt à la question
des tests pour les scrutateurs
en tout cas pour les assesseurs pour
ceux qui tiennent leur revanche sur la
question de la vaccination n'ayant
jamais que le calendrier n'est tenable
aujourd'hui que si justement
l'engagement pris par le président de la
république en termes de vaccination si
certains ouvriers est accepté il ya
aucune raison que l'on soit pas dans de
meilleures situations au moment du vote
c'est à dire le val 27 juin en finale de
réussir à la vaccination en finir
rapidement avec une dernière question
pour jean daniel lévy jean daniel lévy
est ce que les français ont peur d'aller
voter durant cette troisième vague de
l'épidémie
il était près d'un sur deux au cours du
premier tour des dernières élections
municipales
un tiers au cours du deuxième tour des
élections municipales
aujourd'hui on est sensiblement à ce
même niveau là ce sont typiquement le
type de données qui peut être de nature
à pouvoir évoluer assez fortement
ça peut évoluer en fonction de toutes
les garanties qui va être accordée c'est
à dire quelles sont les conditions dans
lesquelles je peux me rendre dans un
bureau de vote
quelles sont les conditions dans
lesquelles vont se passer en fait le
scrutin le dépouillement et qui peuvent
participer et d'un point de vue général
à la mobilisation plus ou moins
importantes on vit quand même de plus en
plus à d'autres virus n'était plus en
plus habitués à pouvoir se rendre dans
des commerces dans la rue à l'extérieur
avec cette connaissance du virus n'est
pas exactement dans la même situation
mais quoi qu'il en sera de la part de
celui qui sont pas forcément les plus
convaincus qu'il est important d'aller
voter aussi qu'il ce qui est gérable un
facteur supplémentaire ou en tout cas
d'une équipe supplémentaire et ce sera
le mot de la fin merci beaucoup merci à
tous les caps d'avoir été sur ce plateau
et à distance pour débattre de
l'organisation de ces élections
régionales départementales et
territoriales et d'ailleurs je précise
qu'à 16h30 il y aura un débat au sénat
avec un discours de jean castex sur
l'organisation de ces élections à suivre
d'ailleurs sur public sénat nous sommes
maintenant à 30 minutes des questions
d'actualité
gouvernement toute notre équipe est
mobilisé et en place avec six jours si
steve jourdan en salle des conférences
du sénat également jean m'assieds sur la
plateforme twitch et puis notre
commentateur parlementaire en tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle quand un calme et
quentin on va beaucoup parler de la
vague de gel qui frappe les cultures
françaises on va en parler cet après
midi oui alex est clairement le sujet
qui fait la une de cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement je
vous le disais il ya quelques instants
pas moins de six questions vont être
posées sur ce sujet déjà à lundi le
ministre les cultures parlais je cite de
la plus grande catastrophe agronomique
de ce début du 21ème siècle alors il y à
quelques instants le porte parole du
gouvernement a évoqué ce sujet en sortie
du conseil des ministres je voulais bien
vous dire ce qu'il a pu et bien évoqué à
ce moment là il a parlé avec cette vague
de gel d'un drame agricole alimentaire
et climatique je cite le porte parole du
gouvernement qui a ajouté nous nous
battrons aux côtés des agriculteurs
alors le gouvernement a déjà évoqué
plusieurs enveloppes exceptionnelle pour
les agriculteurs autre piste envisagée
le recours au chômage partiel ou encore
l'allègement des charges patronales mais
aussi un des fonds exceptionnels et donc
on attend aujourd'hui lors de cette
séance des questions d'actualité de
nouvelles annonces ou des précisions sur
tous ces points
en tout cas il faut le savoir ce gel ils
inquiètent toujours dans les
départements et dans les régions n'y a
pas moins de dix régions sur 13 qui sont
touchants métropole par ce gel depuis
une semaine et on sait que et bien le
thermomètre pourrait descendre sous le
zéro encore jusqu'à demain matin alex
merci beaucoup quentin et on va suivre
toutes les réponses du gouvernement sur
cette vague de gel donc dans 30 minutes
pour les questions d'actualité au sénat
face au danger du variant brésilien jean
castex a annoncé hier la suspension de
tous les vols entre le brésil et la
france
une décision qui était demandé par les
scientifiques par certains responsables
politiques d'opposition c'est l'objet de
notre face à face et j'accueille sur ce
plateau olivier cadic sénateurs
centristes des français établis hors de
france bonjour bonjour
et puis également à lundi
un sénateur les républicains du vaucluse
alors avant bonjour bonjour bonjour
monsieur milan alors avant d'évoquer et
bien cette suspension des vols entre le
brésil et la france on va revenir
concrètement sur cette décision de jean
castex c'est avec jean d'un clan ce week
end le gouvernement a campé sur ses
positions malgré la flambée de
l'épidémie au brésil et la crainte de
l'arrivée massive de son varions
l'exécutif maintien coûte que coûte les
vols avec la france deux jours plus tard
à l'assemblée nationale retournement de
situation le premier ministre annonce
alors linverse nous constatons que la
situation s'aggrave et nous avons dans
décidé de suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre
tous les vols entre le brésil et les
vols suspendus mais aucune concertation
européenne le portugal et l'espagne ont
arrêté leur vol avec le brésil mais ce
n'est pas le cas de l'allemagne ou de
l'italie
malgré tout le gouvernement défend une
mesure nécessaire
est-ce que ça a du sens de prendre sept
autres c'est ce genre de mesures si on
n'est pas aligné à 27
oui c'est à lui sens parce que ça réduit
quand même les liaisons et ce que nous
disaient les scientifiques c'est qu'il
fallait aller vers un durcissement on
partait pas de rien quand même pas dire
qu'on était tout trouvé au brésil depuis
plusieurs semaines depuis le mois de
janvier nous avions imposé pour le
brésil et un certain nombre d'autres
pays en fait tous les pays non-européens
un motif impérieux pour réagit un test
pcr négatif vérifier à l'arrivée la
décision politique
elle est là pour protéger les français
il ya une vraie inquiétude sur le
variant brésilien on suspend les vols en
provenance du brésil ça me paraît la
sagesse ça me paraît un principe de
précaution
malgré tout les sénateurs des français
de l'étranger regrette le manque
d'harmonisation au niveau européen le
portugal a pris cette décision en effet
de suspendre les vols dans la foulée
nous le faisons alors qu'il devrait y
avoir une coordination au niveau
européen pour le faire je pense que
c'est très inquiétant que hannon après
le début de cette pandémie
ne soyons pas en capacité de nous
coordonner globalement pour protéger
l'ensemble des citoyens sur dans un pays
mais également sur le continent le
variant brésilien inquiète notamment par
ta plus grande résistance aux vaccins
certains spécialistes parlent même
d'échappement immunitaire pour l'instant
en france
ils les responsables que de 4% des
contaminations et on va commencer ce
face à face autour de ce variant
brésilien alain milon suspendre les vols
entre le brésil et la france c'est une
décision de bon sens s'est probablement
une décision de d'extrême bon sens mais
probablement insuffisante insuffisante
d'abord parce que c'est pas une décision
européenne
donc il faudra contrôler les vols
brésilien qui est rond dans d'autres
pays d'europe et qui ensuite viendrait
chez nous et ensuite je pense qu'il faut
aller au delà puisque on s'aperçoit par
exemple qu'en argentine le virus
brésilien et en août et qu'il fait aussi
beaucoup de dégâts donc il faudrait que
finalement nous ayons des mesures prises
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de l'amérique
latine n'est pas uniquement du brésil
on sait très bien que lorsqu'on laisse
le virus circulait comme il a circulé en
particulier au brésil
il y aura de plus en plus de variants de
plus en plus de variants qui seront
agressifs et de plus en plus de
variantes qui seront très probablement
résistant à la vaccination
donc si on ne fait pas si on ne prend
pas les mesures nécessaires pour
empêcher ces variants de venir chez nous
on va avoir des populations vaccinées
sécurisé qui seront en contact avec un
variant qui lui résistera à la
vaccination au lit mais il a dit qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette décision
de suspendre les vols entre le brésil et
la france
je les trouvais démagogique précipiter
il réfléchit démagogique parce que
ça a été dit la veille par le ministre
des transports on parle de 50 voir
l'extrait relative qui reviennent chaque
jour du brésil on parle de sao paulo qui
est un club
d'avion donc vous revenez de buenos
aires santiago du chili vous passé par
sao paulo pour revenir en france donc
quand on bloque la liaison sao paulo on
bloque un hub précipité elle s'est faite
sous la contrainte on l'a bien vu il ya
une pression forte d'ailleurs de débuter
du président du groupe l'est républicain
l'assemblée nationale qu'avec amis
vraiment une pression très forte sur le
gouvernement pour le faire très vite
parce que on a besoin de donner des
signes il faut donner l'illusion que
l'on agisse aujourd'hui on sait très
bien que ça concerne que 50 personnes
si c'était si grave que ça écoutez les
britanniques ils ont pris cette décision
de fermer tous les vols avec le brésil
le 15 janvier à 4 heures du matin il n'y
a pas donc au moins si on pense que ça a
une importance excessive grave que ça on
devrait s'adresser aux français qui sont
rentrés du brésil dans la dernière
semaine
s'assurer qu'ils sont bien chez eux on
devrait prendre des mesures
à côté on devrait prévenir parce que les
gens quand ils doivent revenir de façon
précipitée au repartir de façon
précipitée il faut quand même qu'il
fasse un test de 72 heures donc et ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que toutes
les mesures d'accompagnement aujourd'hui
le test de 72 heures les sept jours de
quarantaine que l'on s'impose chez soi
ça veut dire que ça n'a pas de sens ça
ne sert à rien ça n'empêche pas de
passer elle veut faire passer le virus
donc pour toutes ces raisons là
effectivement le jeudi que c'est
démagogique et maintenant la situation
qui est impactée par ça ce sont les
français du brésil et l'avait le land
enfin des classes a été annoncé marie
godefroy alain rey sont françois cessieu
les élus des français du brésil tout de
suite
écrivant dix ans mais c'est nous qui
sommes directement concernés et là on
nous empêche de rentrer or il ya une
décision du conseil d'état qui dit qu'on
ne peut pas empêcher les gens cette
rentrée est justement au nom de cet avis
du conseil d'état
et bien ce week-end le ministre des
transports jean baptiste djebbari a
estimé que c'était impossible
juridiquement de suspendre les vols
entre la france et le brésil
on va l'écouter
pourquoi on a gardé ses lignes parce que
s'est imposée par le droit c'est que le
conseil d'état nous a dit que les héros
sortis sans français et les résidents en
france au nom de la liberté de
circulation devait pouvoir continuer à
venir raison pour laquelle et cela peut
être fait par exemple au portugal où
dans d'autres pays
elles sont pour laquelle nous avons
encore renforcé le protocole sanitaire
et garder quelques lignes mais encore
une fois je lis et 50 personnes par jour
alors mis non c'est une décision
contraignante au niveau des libertés
pour nos ressortissants français au
brésil mais l'urgence sanitaire doit
primer l'urgence sanitaire doit primer
contraignantes au niveau des français
qui viennent du brésil
non ils font les tests si les tests sont
négatifs ils peuvent venir
tranquillement s'il était sont positifs
il faut les isoler on ne peut pas
admettre le principe d'une personne qui
porteuse du coc vide brésilien arrivé
sur notre territoire et librement aller
partout il faut à tout prix que cette
personne là une fois que le test effet
une fois que la positivité déclaré une
fois que le séquençage est fait et que
le test qu'aux vide brésilien est
déclarée il faut isoler ces personnes ne
faut pas les empêcher de venir
il faut simplement les tester les
séquences et des isolés parce que du
coup la concrètement avec la suspension
des vols bien ces français du brésil il
ne pleut ils ne peuvent plus rentrer
dans leur pays
pour l'instant c'est une mesure
sanitaire obligatoire
moi je considère que pour l'instant ce
qui se passe au brésil met en danger
l'ensemble des politiques mises en place
par tous les gouvernements un peu
mondiaux qui ont vacciné leurs
populations et qui ont vacciné leurs
populations contre un virus quelque
ovide 19 transformer en commises en
convient de 20 mais qui pour l'instant
les protège ce virus qui est en train de
se développer au brésil est un virus qui
semble-t-il est résistant vaccination et
s'armer en danger lance en aux
populations ça remet en danger
l'économie mondiale se remet en danger
tous les pays qui ont décidé de vacciner
leur population et c'est un virus qui se
balade un peu partout notamment en
amérique latine
olivier cadic est ce qu'on n'aurait pas
intérêt à également suspendre nos
liaisons avec tous les pays d'amérique
latine fois qu'il est aussi au canada
ces variants brésilien mais il est déjà
en france mais aussi en france il est
déjà en france a été déclarée en moselle
voilà en moselle c'est trop tard donc de
toutes façons il est déjà là restez pas
une raison pour accepter tout le monde
mais la question mais aujourd'hui les
brésiliens ne peuvent pas venir en
france
ils les vols étaient maintenus mais les
brésiliens ne peut venir en france que
s'ils ont un vrai motif ils ne peuvent
pas c'est donc spécifiquement une mesure
orientée vers les sur les français du
brésil etc ça et aujourd'hui il faut
quand même comprendre que après plus
d'un an de situation les français de
l'étranger se sentent stigmatisés
vous savez c'est pas bon quand il ya
huit députés les républicains qui à
l'assemblée nationale propose un
amendement pour supprimer la
représentation des français de
l'étranger
il ya un moment où on sent que
effectivement ils sont six gars
stigmatisés et là aujourd'hui on va dire
en suspend les vols mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec cayenne la plus grande
frontière terrestre de la france est
avec le brésil
donc est-ce qu'on ferme la frontière
donc entre la guyane et le brésil
donc on voit bien aujourd'hui que nous
sommes sur une mesure d'urgence qui est
prise dans l'urgence non préparé non
réfléchi vous rendez compte que
l'ambassadeur du brésil en france a pris
cette information par les réseaux
sociaux tous le patron d'air france au
brésil
la prix pareils par les réseaux sociaux
ça veut dire que la mesure n'est pas
préparé n'ai pas réfléchi et c'est ça
qu'on est en train de mettre en cause en
ce moment donc vraiment moi ce qui me
rassure c'est que j'ai eu un combinat un
coup de fil avec le cabinet de clément
bonne avant de avant cette ce débat
puisque entre l'asc disette premier
ministre en disant s'est arrêtée jusqu'à
nouvel ordre
le décret dit c'est interdit jusqu'au 19
avril donc jusqu'à dimanche parce qu'il
ya aussi les gens qui sont ici qui
doivent repartir au brésil
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils restent en
france donc il faut bien trouver une
solution interdire les vols la
communication n'est jamais une solution
ce qu'il faut c'est trouver des mesures
d'accompagnement et là on va se
retrouver tout ce qu'ils soient
efficaces parce que notre objectif est
de faire arrêter la circulation du virus
c'est pas d'arrêter la circulation des
gens il faut avoir des mesures efficaces
contre l'arrivée de nouveaux variants
sur notre territoire
alain milon et ce qu'il faut en
isolement plus contraint c'est à dire
que jusqu'à présent la personne fait une
déclaration sur l'honneur pour respecter
son isolement de sept jours mais est ce
que on peut imaginer en france une
quarantaine obligatoire avec une mise
dans un hôtel comme je vous disais tout
à l'heure je suis d'accord avec olivier
cadic sur sur le fait qu'il faut quand
même faire attention à ce qu'on fait
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure il
faut tester tous les français qui
viennent d'amérique latine sur notre
territoire il faut les tester
en attendant le résultat du test il faut
les isoler et non pas les isolés au
milieu familial mais faire un petit peu
ce qui se fait en asie c'est à dire
isolé dans une chambre dans un hôtel en
attendant le résultat avec un séquençage
obligatoire puisque si on fait un test
et qu'on a un test positif ça veut pas
dire que cette positivité soit dû à un
qu'ovide brésilien si le séquençage
prouve le comité brésilien il faut
isoler mais isolé véritablement ou alors
on se retrouve dans la situation où on a
l'ensemble de notre population vaccinée
ou non vacciner à nouveau donjon isolé
sous la contrainte
un peu comme en asie tout à fait olivier
cadic cet isolement en contre un vous y
est favorable
quelques jours avant et bien la
vérification du test et si jamais il est
positif
plusieurs jours après vous savez dans ce
domaine se sera jamais assez les chinois
ils en sont au point où ils demandent à
ce que leur population s'isole dix jours
même avant de reprendre l'avion vers
vers la chine
il ya des étapes
de façon de le faire il peut y avoir un
isolement c'est dur un isolement nous
avons des comptes dix jours dans une
chambre d'hôtel même un prisonnier a le
droit de sortir une heure par jour là
vous ne bougez pas de votre chambre
d'hôtel
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très dur il ya aussi d'autres techniques
pour s'isoler chez soi c'est d'avoir une
application un état qui a de moins de
moyens on peut dire le liban aujourd'hui
le liban est en capacité de vous faire
télécharger une application pour
garantir le lieu où vous allez vous
trouvez donc il ya différentes
différents outils qui serait à
disposition mais ça ça serait peut-être
bien que l'on revienne là-dessus et
qu'on fasse des débats posé réfléchi au
parlement pour déterminer tous ensemble
quelle est la bonne mesure parce qu'il
faut que ça fasse consensus
stop aux mesures décidées en quelques
minutes sous la pression de députés qui
se font un peu comment dire virulent
alors qu'on est à quelques semaines
d'une élection et qu'on comprend bien
que tout ça n'est pas sans
arrière-pensée donc là aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut c'est des passionnés tout ça
et on prendre des mesures consensuelles
un mot sur la philosophie générale le
prix dans la république le dis souvent
il va falloir vivre avec le virus on est
dans des mesures sanitaires quand même
allégé un confinement allégé où on peut
se déplacer à l'an mil on est ce qu'on
peut vraiment vivre avec les variants
gerbe also know brésil il a eu des
mesures sanitaires très souple il a
refusé le confinement voit le résultat
est ce qu'il faut plus de fermeté dans
la mesure sanitaire
si si on a affaire à des variants
habituel on a beaucoup parlé du variant
anglais qui finalement jeu face à la
vaccination ne résiste pas on a parlé de
certains variants breton qui face à
l'arrestation ne résiste pas le vrai
problème c'est que quand on permet la
circulation complète du virus
il se développe des variants différents
et parfois dans ces variants il y en a
un qui est résistant et c'est ce qui se
passe au brésil actuellement donc il
faut à la fois vacciner nos populations
pendant un temps empêcher le virus de
circuler un tank est généralement d'un
mois ou deux mois
si l'ensemble des fossiles de la
population est vaccinée et si le virus
ne circule plus il ya plus de variants
là le problème c'est que si le
virus circule si le variant circulent on
va se retrouver devant une situation à
nouveau catastrophiques du point de vue
la santé publique et du point de vue de
l'économie mondiale c'est ce qu'il faut
faire attention et olivier cadic la
raison de parler de l'inde en a
certainement aussi des variants qui vont
arriver qui seront probablement aussi
agressif que le variant brésilien par la
suite ce qu'il faut c'est une politique
européenne globale accepté par tout le
monde ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement et une politique mondiale
global et il faut la sq avait demandé l'
oms par rapport à son kovac c'est de
faire en sorte que les populations qui
n'ont pas les moyens de se vacciner soit
vacciné par l'intermédiaire des des pays
riches qui payent ces vaccinations à ces
populations
sinon on ne s'en sortira pas avant deux
ou trois ans alors messieurs dans
windows et dans une dizaine une douzaine
de minutes les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement vont commencer pour en
parler on va rejoindre notre streamer
politique alors qu'on voit et bien et
les sénateurs qui arrive à ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et on va
retrouver notre streamer politique jean
m'assieds qui va suivre cette séance sur
sa plateforme
twitch gens qu'est ce que t'as
communauté attend de cette séance de
questions d'actualité
ben écoute alex pas de surprise comme
vous en parliez sur le plateau à
l'instant le variant brésilien le
variant brésilien qui inquiète et qui
fait se poser des questions pour les
internautes des questions qu'ils
aimeraient bien posée au gouvernement
par la voix du coût des sénateurs et des
sénatrices cet après-midi les questions
sur la fermeture des frontières le
gouvernement va-t-il fermer les
frontières avec le brésil l'interdiction
des vols a été annoncé hier par jean
castex mais quid des autres pays
d'amérique latine quid de la guyane ya
beaucoup de questions qui se pose est
comment va se passer la période de
quarantaine ou de d'isolement pour les
personnes arrivant du brésil voilà des
questions qui se posent sur les mesures
concrètes qui vont être prises et puis
plus globalement autour du coc vite des
questions de plus en plus pressantes sur
la stratégie de la praye la préco vide
alors on parle des élections les uns et
27 juin prochains bon pour les sénateurs
et les élus locaux c'est important pour
les internautes
ça pose des questions plus larges en dix
ans les élections c'est sympa mais le
reste qui et comment ça va se passer le
mois de juin le mois de mai le mois de
juillet comment est-ce que les choses
vont réouvrir est ce qu'on va avoir
recours à un pass sanitaires ou un
passeport ou un passeport vaccinale même
pour aller faire les magasins ont mangé
au restaurant aller au cinéma
beaucoup de questions se posent et on
attend de la part du gouvernement des
clarifications sur la stratégie de
sortie de crise qui commence à attiser
donc par le président de la république
donc tu vois il ya des vraies attentes
de la part des internautes et on a hâte
que les sénateurs et sénatrices pose ces
questions
merci beaucoup gens et puis durant cette
séance il sera est bien question de la
vague de gel qui frappe les cultures
françaises avec de graves conséquences
pour les récoltes et pour en parler on
va aller dans la salle des conférences
du sénat retrouver steve jourdain qui
est avec franck montaugé sénateur
socialiste du gers
oui franck montaugé bonjour on va parler
évidemment de cet épisode de froid qui a
ravagé les cultures françaises question
à la fois simple et compliqué dans votre
département comment ça se passe et ce
que vous pouvez évaluer d'ores et déjà
les dégâts ont livré le sun tzu de
pincourt
mais les dégâts pour des céréales aussi
on a les colzas voire peut-être même des
blés qui sont touchés l'élémentaire est
en cours l'évaluation est en cours et
voilà on craint aussi par rapport aux
jours qui arrivent parce que s'il ya le
deuxième couche
évidemment en termes de production ça
sera quasiment nul la question qui se
pose maintenant c'est évidemment les
aides qui vont être débloqués pour les
agriculteurs pour les producteurs le
gouvernement il a annoncé le
déplafonnement du régime des calamités
agricoles il a aussi annoncé la mise en
place d'un fonds d'urgence spécial ça
suffit ça suffit pas selon vos bons je
pense que le gouvernement
un visage des mesures qui sont à la
hauteur de la situation catastrophique
c'est le rôle d'ailleurs de l'état et en
dernier ressort de faire jouer la
solidarité nationale
on est dans cette situation là
aujourd'hui donc ils font que au niveau
européen au niveau national toutes les
conditions soient soient donnés pour
qu'effectivement ces aides
puis c'est arrivé le plus rapidement
possible parra pour la à la production
mais qui ne pourra pas se faire
et pour pour préparer l'année prochaine
parce que c'est aussi ça qui se pose
comme comme franck montaugé vous aviez
fait voter ici même au sénat une
proposition de loi sur les assurances
agricoles ce texte n'avait pas été
repris ensuite par le gouvernement
pourquoi on tarde à réagir
réformer cette ces assurances agricoles
dont on parle depuis déjà plusieurs
années
oui absolument ce qu'on est en train de
vivre nous nous rappelle d'abord la
grande difficulté du métier
d'agriculteur
si indispensable à nos vies à tous et
est en même temps la fragilité
de ses activités par rapport au
réchauffement climatique aux phénomènes
climatiques sanitaires environnementaux
qui se multiplient dans la fréquence
donc il est grand temps qu'on se
préoccupe de la question effectivement
des outils de gestion des risques
il n'y a pas que l'assurance l'assurance
est un outil parmi d'autres mais il ya
aussi l'assurance seulement 30 % des
agriculteurs sont aujourd'hui assurés
ces assurances elles sont trop chers
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui que la pénétration de
l'assurance au niveau de l'agriculture
française et est encore faible
il ya là il ya une acculturation qui est
nécessaire à par rapport à ça entre deux
épisodes on a été on a plutôt tendance à
oublier voilà ce que peut apporter ce
cadeau nécessaire l'assurance
et puis quand on est confronté comme
c'est le cas la situation est dramatique
on se dit que ça serait bien
qu'effectivement ce soit en soit assurée
alors moi je crois qu'il ya des
conditions à réunir faute faute de quoi
on n'y arrivera pas leur lesquels je
pense qu'il faudrait que les
agriculteurs aient les moyens il faut
leur donner les moyens d'accéder à des
assurances
quelles que soient leurs cultures leurs
activités agricoles et sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
si on n'arrive pas à faire ça je pense
que ce sera difficile on trouvera pas de
compagnies d'assurances pour prendre les
risques et il ya une autre question
absolument majeur et qui se pose et qui
inquiète d'ailleurs les assurances et
qui sont très très très très réticente à
s'engager c'est l'arrêt en cas de
catastrophe
de deux catastrophes importantes comme
celle qu'on vit comment les assureurs
face à des risques voilà qui ne peuvent
être couverts peuvent être malgré tout
aidé et là c'est la place la sorite et
national voire européen qui se posera si
effectivement on avait voté en 2016
au groupe socialiste une proposition de
loi dont le but était de créer un fonds
de stabilisation du revenu agricole
il ya deux sujets dans l'agriculture le
niveau du revenu et la régularité du
revenu et c'est un des sujets liés à
l'assurance ou en tout cas la gestion
des risques agricoles un sujet dont on
va parler dans l'hémicycle merci
beaucoup monsieur le sénateur-maire ce
produit à mes questions
merci beaucoup steve alain milon votre
département le vaucluse en département
aime beaucoup de cultures maraîchères il
est frappé par cette vague de jeunes
quelles sont les conséquences elles sont
elles sont considérables je voudrais
revenir y aller mollo gel cette année où
il ya une destruction à 80 90 % à peu
près de l'ensemble de la viticulture et
pareil pour l'arboriculture
il ya eu l'année passée locaux vides
avec une diminution considérable de la
consommation
il ya eu de l'année passée l'année avant
les mesures trump qui ont entraîné des
augmentations importantes de taxes
américaines qui ont entraîné une
diminution des ventes il ya eu il ya
quelques années en arrière on s'en
souvient peu les mesures contre la
russie au moment où la russie avait
avait engagé la guerre de crimée qui ont
entraîné pour les arboriculteurs en
partie que la pomme et la poire
vauclusienne une diminution considérable
des ventes en ligne sur vita en russie
pardon et donc il est plus que
nécessaire que désormais l'état prenne
en main cette difficulté majeure de nos
agriculteurs en global évidemment au
niveau national je pense que cette fois
ci ils ne peuvent plus se contenter
uniquement de promesses faut aller bien
au delà il faut aller rapidement au delà
dans les compensations financières
mais très rapidement mais beaucoup
d'attentes de la part des sénateurs sur
ce soutien aux agriculteurs
messieurs il reste très peu de temps
c'est bientôt la fin de ce face à face
olivier cadic vouliez
dia un dernier mot sur ce variant
brésilien je ne voudrais pas que le
brésil se sentent stigmatisés par la
france le brésil à la plus grande
frontière terrestre avec la france qui
est la guyane les problèmes du brésil
sont aussi les problèmes de la france et
nous devons les aider à les surmonter
n'oublions pas que le brésil à vacciner
deux fois plus de population que les
français merci mais ce sera le mot de la
fin de ce face à face et dans quelques
minutes la séance de questions
d'actualité du sénat va commencer on va
retrouver steve jourdain en salle des
conférences avec philippe bas d'abord
pour parler et bien du projet loi pour
plus de confiance dans la justice qui
est présenté aujourd'hui par le ministre
eric dupond moretti
oui avec dupont moretti à monsieur bah
que vous connaissez bien vous avez eu
quelques anicroches on va dire ça comme
ça ici au sénat avec lui il présente
donc son projet de loi pour une réforme
de la justice de grandes avancées la
réforme des cours d'assises et la
généralisation des audiences filmé bonne
mauvaise idée selon vous ce projet comme
dans beaucoup des projets de loi quand
nous présente aujourd'hui il ya du bon
du moins bon et du mauvais
je crois que parmi les bonnes choses
s'il ya une chose que vous n'avez pas
cité
il ya le fait que les enquêtes
préliminaires qui aujourd'hui ne donne
pas accès aux personnes qui en font
l'objet au contenu du dossier vont
s'ouvrir à davantage de contradictoire
c'est-à-dire permettent aux droits de la
défense de s'exercer plus tôt mais
s'agissant des deux points que vous
soulevez juste suis étonné que le garde
des sceaux après avoir été un grand
défenseur des jurys d'assises proposent
de les supprimer
et personnellement jusqu'à ce qu'il me
convaincre du contraire de la réforme et
pas des cyprès je considère que le
maintien du jury d'assises est important
et que l'expérimentation des cours
criminelles c'est à dire où on tous
condamnés à de lourdes peines de prison
sans jury d'assises n'est pas une
expérience à généraliser
s'agissant de la possibilité de filmer
les procès je crois qu'il faut s'engager
dans cette voie qu'avec une extrême
prudence
les accusés
alors même qu'il pourrait être innocenté
ne doivent pas être livrés en pâture au
public et je crois que ça modifie les
comportements quand les choses sont
filmés et que ça n'est pas forcément la
bonne chose à faire pour accoucher d'une
bonne décision de justice
philippe à l'actualité c'est aussi ce
report d'une semaine des élections
régionales et départementales annonces
du gouvernement annonce de jean castex
bonne mauvaise idée selon vous je crois
que vous êtes contre l'essentiel est
sauf puisque la date des élections est
maintenue en jeu ce qui sauf cas de
force majeure qui se révèlerait dix
jours avant l'élection
me paraît être une bonne chose on ne
joue pas avec les calendriers électoraux
maintenant je me demande pourquoi on en
est arrivé à cette décision de reporter
à la toute fin du mois de juin le second
tour c'est pas une semaine de
vaccination plus c'est s'est excusé moi
c'est un argument idiot deux millions de
personnes vaccinées en plus comme oui
mais ne seront pas immunisés quand elles
ont été vaccinées le lundi pour le
dimanche donc si vous voulez ça n'a pas
de sens en revanche je crains fort que
même si les vacances scolaires 2
débarque en juillet une partie des
français soit parti en vacances ce week
end là et je me dis pourquoi prendre le
risque alors que on craint beaucoup
cette abstention de se mesurer à un
autre facteur d'abstention un facteur
supplémentaire d'abstention philippe bas
vous aller interpeller le gouvernement
dans quelques instants
au sujet du conseil des ministres qu'est
ce que vous reprochez quel est le
problème aujourd'hui quel problème des
conseils des ministres aujourd'hui en
france le problème c'est qu'ils ne
seraient une plus à l'élysée dans les
formes constitutionnel mais à distance
la plupart des milices étant relié par
un révisé
et par visioconférence est ce que c'est
une vraie délibération sur le plan
institutionnel est ce que ça a sur la
collégialité et la solidarité des
décisions gouvernementales sur le plan
juridique
est ce que ça ne risque pas de mettre en
fragilité les décisions qui sont prises
pour des nominations très importante
pour des projets de l'homme savait que
le conseil constitutionnel ne permet pas
la délibération à distance à n'importe
quelles conditions par exemple pour
l'assemblée nationale il a censuré la
réforme de son règlement
et vous savez aussi que le conseil
constitutionnel vérifie quand il est
saisi d'une loi qui vient d'être votée
que la délibération du conseil des
ministres s'est fait dans des goûts
conditions constitutionnelles donc nous
avons un problème je voudrais que le
premier ministre nous donne son
sentiment sur cette question et
peut-être demande au président de la
république très rapidement de remettre
de l'ordre dans la maison en réunissant
normalement conseil des ministres le
palais de l'elysée est assez grand pour
assurer la sécurité sanitaire des
membres du gouvernement sans qu'ils
soient dans la promiscuité mais on verra
ce que le gouvernement va répondre à
votre question merci beaucoup
philippe bas je vous laisse rejoindre
l'hémicycle les missiles justement où
rejoint quand un calme et quentin
données où le programme est bien steve
on attend pas moins de six questions
consacré au gel des cultures alors que
gérard larcher le président est en train
de s'installer au moment où je vous
parle juste derrière moi dans
l'hémicycle où le silence se fait pour
cette séance de questions d'actualité où
il sera donc question beaucoup
d'agriculture avec donc six questions
dont la toute première qui va suivre
dans quelques secondes
on attend aussi donc la question de
philippe babin que vous venez d'évoquer
steve est également une question des
communistes sur la fusion entre veolia
et suez ou encore une question est bien
sûr les oubliés du ségur de la santé
voilà le programme c'est parti
là on parle si d'observation il y en a
t'il en séance je n'en vois pas il est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
messieurs le premier ministre mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun observera à la fois le respect
des uns et des autres le respect du
temps de parole de ne pas oublier
l'ensemble des mesures sanitaires que
nous prenons entrées sorties et
comportements divers j'en profite pour
leur rappeler au début de cette séance
je vais donner la parole si vous le
voulez bien à notre collègue daniel
seulement pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoires qui avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation
face à cet épisode de gel d'une ampleur
sans précédent qui touche depuis une
semaine une go large partie de la france
je souhaiterais d'abord adresser toute
ma solidarité aux paysannes et aux
paysans qui ont perdu en une nuit le
fruit d'une année de travail des
vignobles du chablis aux arboriculteurs
de la drôme en passant par les semis des
betteraves de seine et marne c'est la
désolation
cette catastrophe ne peut être prise
comme un phénomène isolé
c'est une catastrophe liée bien
évidemment au dérèglement climatique
elle fait suite à de nombreux précédents
et ce type d'aléas se reproduira un
rythme difficilement soutenable pour la
pérennité du régime actuel
d'indemnisation le déclenchement de la
procédure de calamité agricole ils sont
des plafonnements et est bien sûr
indispensable mais ce système n'est plus
adapté pour faire face à ces épisodes
climatiques extrêmes à répétition il
faut attendre de longs mois pour être
indemnisé
ce qui ne permet pas de maintenir à flot
des trésoreries déjà exsangues
les critères d'éligibilité pour accéder
à ces fonds sont drastiques avec un
seuil qui évince un grand nombre de
petites exploitations sans compter
toutes celles qui en sont totalement
exclus les viticulteurs
recourir à des assurances privées
inadaptée et coûteuse il faut engager
maintenant des mesures structurantes qui
permettent de couvrir tous les risques
climatiques pour toutes les cultures
l'excellent rapport sénatorial de nicole
bonnefoy apporte en ce sens une bonne
base de réflexion
monsieur le ministre votre prédécesseur
didier guillaume s'était engagée il ya
plus de deux ans à remettre à plat le
régime de calamité agricole
est ce que les travaux ont avancé depuis
merci quand vous répondre la parole et
au ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur normandie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur salmon l'épisode climatique que
nous avons vécu est absolument
exceptionnel extraordinaire
il faut avoir en tête que nous avons en
l'espace de quelques jours
d'abord atteindre des records de chaleur
puis atteint des records de froid
parfois dans les mêmes zones
j'étais ce matin auprès des équipes de
météo france et météo france témoigner
de ce caractère à la fois singulier
exceptionnel d'une violence extrême qui
a touché près de 10 régions sur 13 sur
le territoire métropolitain est comme
gelée qualifier il y a quelques jours
cet épisode exceptionnel a donné lieu à
la plus grande catastrophe agronomique
de ce début du 21ème siècle
songez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que ce sont des centaines de
milliers d'hectares qui ont été impactés
nous étions avec le premier ministre
avec olivier du soft dans la drôme dans
l'ardèche il ya quelques jours où des
champs entiers d'arbres fruitiers sebo
abricots ces belles cerises de ces
territoires qui en espace de quelques
nuits en débit en dépit de la guerre
véritable menée par nos agriculteurs
pour combattre ces vagues de froid ont
été littéralement
cramer le problème du gel c'est qu'il
est invisible
l'émotion était forte mais l'émotion
aurait été encore plus forte de la part
de notre société
si cela n'avait pas été un gel mais si
cela avait été un incendie impactant des
centaines de milliers d'hectares
or la réalité est là et la détresse de
nos agriculteurs de nos agricultrices
elle est totale parfois celles aux
revenus de toute cette saison pour les
arbres fruitiers qui ne viendra pas
parfois c'est le revenu de l'année
prochaine pour les viticulteurs qui ne
viendront pas et donc nous devons faire
une réponse que je détaillerai par la
suite mais nous devons faire une réponse
à la hauteur de l'événement exceptionnel
que nous venons de vivre à la fois sur
des mesures de court terme et j'y
reviendrai à la fois sur des mesures de
long terme et vous avez mille fois
raison aujourd'hui le système de
l'assurance n'est plus gré pour faire
face à de tels épisodes sur chalon
merci monsieur le ministre pour cette
réponse c'est is pisode nous rappelle
aussi combien notre modèle agricole il
perd spécialisé trop souvent en mode aux
cultures est très fragile face au
changement climatique
les politiques publiques doivent
soutenir et financer des modèles
agricoles plus résilience est une
priorité
elle doit d'accompagner l'adaptation des
systèmes de production et la transition
des fermes dans des systèmes agro
écologiques la future pac et la loi
climat sont des opportunités uniques
pour répondre à ces enjeux il faudra
être à la hauteur et agir dans l'instant
est intéressant est essentiel mais il
faut aller et voir plus loin
mais si par là notre collègue dany
wattebled pour le groupe les
indépendants république et territoires
de la parole
mais je président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à monsieur mise l'intérieur et
porte sur nos prochaines cartes à son
identité numérique
la khl et elle l'a encore démontré les
startups ont réussi à terrasser les
grands de l'industrie pharmaceutique en
matière d'innovation contre la copie de
résultat alors que sanofi 106 400
personnes en recherche développement vol
mais n'at elle pas quitter le territoire
et prospère aidés par des capteurs
anglais où est la france
l'histoire va-t-elle malheureusement se
répéter cette cadence et numérique
keith aulie sécuritaire n'est qu'un
miroir aux alouettes qui ne traîne
tiendra pas sur le long terme
la technique retenue son ancienne datant
en moyenne de 10 ans et d'ailleurs la
durée de vie de canne entier et de 10
ans cherchez l'erreur
un exemple l'entrejeu suisse qui a été
retenu à plus de 30 ans d'ancienneté
on peut l'acheter sur une plateforme de
vente en ligne chinoise à l'express pour
cent soit 17 euros
on pourrait aussi s'étonner d'avoir
retenu une photo en noir et blanc
ici une emprise américaine hall une
photo couleur d'un de nos leaders
français mondial français de même il est
étonnant que la reconnaissance physique
du document n'est pas être retenu le
process france et innovant d'une société
née de la french tech soutenu par la bpi
et qui se classe dans le top mondial en
innovation sécuritaire monsieur le
ministre comment l'imprimé nationale
garante de cette carte à noter nationale
peut préférer des égoïstes étrangères
est dépassé à noter que j françaises
innovantes
alors que l'on sait que ces cartes
peuvent être de contrefaites pouvez vous
monsieur le ministre nous rassurer à
double titre
premièrement sur le fait que toutes les
garanties sont bien prises en matière de
compétitivité technologique et
économique
et deuxièmement au delà de ce sujet
précis comment mieux intégrer nos
startups françaises dans la commande
publique
on a parlé de celui de l'intérieur
monsieur leur manable parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur on a déjà eu l'occasion de
parler de cette question il s'agit en
effet que la loi c'est la loi qui donne
le monopole à l'imprimerie nationale et
qui définit des critères les sociétés
notamment la société derrière lesquelles
se posent d'autres questions a été
refusée par l'imprimerie nationale et ne
m'appartient pas d'intervenir
dans le choix des sociétés lorsque
notamment la loi prévoit un ca nombre de
critères que chacun connaît lorsqu'il a
géré les collectivités locales
bled monsieur le ministre je veux
simplement vous dire de voir nos voisins
allemands estoniens s'ils n'ont pas
hésité à retenir à tout petits français
est ce que je vous parlais et d'autres
d'ailleurs
pour l'heure quelqu'un dit numérique et
surtout il n'est jamais trop tard
puisque on est en période
d'expérimentation dans deux départements
merci la parole est notre collègue
gilbert bouchet pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le ministre
la question est relative aux dégâts
causés par le gel sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire
ces dégâts sont d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle on estime par exemple
dans mon département de la drôme que la
filière fruitière a d'ores et déjà perdu
presque l'intégralité des productions et
que les céréales et les vignobles pour
être fortement impactée dans plusieurs
régions aussi permettez-moi de vous
adresser de cartons un carton bleu pour
votre réactivité en venant à la drôme
dans les 48 heures qui ont suivi
l'épisode du gel un carton rouge
car les aides prévues suite au gel de
2020 n'ont toujours pas été versés
nos paysans ne peut plus se contenter de
belles promesses
il en faut aussi des actes et ce à la
vitesse de vos déplacements
nos agriculteurs sont à genoux sans
aucune trésorerie alors que par exemple
les bougies de protection contre le gel
coûte 4000 euros à l'hectare difficile
de se réapprovisionner
sachant que cet achat n'est pas
considérée comme un investissement
mais quand une charge de fonctionnement
donc non amortissable vous avez annoncé
que l'état va débloquer des enveloppes
et cèpes sonel c'est indispensable mais
insuffisante pour venir en aide à ceux
qui ont tout perdu
il faut réfléchir à des mesures
structurelles et pérenne afin de
prévenir ce notre agriculture de ces
aléas climatiques de plus en plus
fréquents notamment par le biais de la
création d'êtres à l'adaptation des
exploitations au changement climatique
afin de les faire évoluer vers des
cultures moins fragiles ou moins précoce
m'est égal
d'entamer un travail de fond sur le
processus assurantiel ma question est la
suivante
concrètement sous quel délai les
sinistres pourront-ils bénéficier des
aides promises au delà de ces situations
de détresse pour le futur call mesures à
envisager ou de prendre la garantie de
l'avenir de ce secteur merci quand vous
rendre la parole et organise de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation monsieur
de normandie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai évoqué plusieurs points et y est je
note que vous délivrez un certain nombre
de cartons enfin parfois lorsque vous
évoquez les attentes de nos agriculteurs
je crois que vous savez à quel point je
à des mesures ses attentes
mais je crois aussi que vous savez à
quel point je ne suis pas de ceux qui
disent des choses et qu'il ne les font
pas derrière vous pour vous donne un
exemple vous parlez à très juste titre
des mesures de prévention pour adapter
nos cultures des mesures de prévention
pour lutter contre ces épisodes
songez monsieur le sénateur mais je sais
que vous le savez que dans le cadre du
plan france relance dès septembre
dernier dès septembre dernier nous avons
mis en place sous l'autorité du premier
ministre une enveloppe de 100 millions
d'euros pour financer par exemple c'est
tour antigel ses filets paragrêle
l'immense difficulté et vous le savez
très bien dans la drôme c'est
malheureusement un terrible exemple de
ce qui s'est passé
l'immense difficulté c'est que dans
l'état actuel des dispositifs de lutte
les tours antigel les braseros les
bougies l'aspersion dans l'état actuel
de tous ces dispositifs quand il était
déployé sur un champ d'abricotiers dans
la drôme
et bien pour autant pour autant la
culture a quand même je les ai donc ça
montre tout l'ampleur du défi alors je
vous rejoins sur un deuxième point c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nos dispositifs
ils doivent être rapides mais que force
est de constater que tous les
dispositifs comme la calamité agricole
ça prend en moyenne neuf mois dans notre
pays et donc le sujet et c'est à la
demande du premier ministre nous allons
mettre en place ces dispositifs
habituels mais nous allons créer un
deuxième fonds un fonds exceptionnel un
fonds basé sur les pertes d'excédent
brut d'exploitation est un fonds qui
devra arriver dès lors que les revenus
habituels n'arrivent pas par exemple
pour les abricotiers de la drôme c'est
dès cet été pour la viticulture c'est un
peu après voilà comment nous allons
approcher la chose mais vous dites
qu'ils sont insuffisants nous sommes en
train de les grès et dont vous dites
qu'ils sont assez suffisant avant même
que nous soyons se prononcer sur leur
montant donc nous en parlerons dans
quelques jours je vous remercie et j'en
prends bien note
il faut également parler des saisonniers
qui sont un véritable don de problèmes
et ensuite ceux qui transforment les
fruits également puisque ils vont avoir
de sérieux problèmes d'approvisionnement
enfin en tout cas j'ai bien pris note et
nous en reparlerons merci merci la
parole de notre collègue alain dufaut
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole ce président mr
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je vais poser une question
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation de questions redondantes
depuis ce que j'allais parler aussi du
gel sujet qui viennent d'être évoqués
par mes collègues
effectivement ces derniers ont évoqué
des pertes concernant les arbres
fruitiers dans leurs divers départements
pas ce qui me concerne je parlerai de
viticulture dans le gers puisque 50 à
100 % des vignobles ont été détruits il
y aura une perte donc considérable je
sais que aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre vous avez activé le régime des
calamités agricoles
mais il serait bon que vous précisiez le
dispositif et la date des versements aux
et dignité pour ces viticulteurs qui ont
souffert de ces dommages
par ailleurs monsieur le premier
ministre
vous avez annoncé la mise en place d'un
dispositif supplémentaire de solidarité
nationale quel sera le rôle des banques
et des assurances dans ce dispositif
vous avez également la possibilité dans
le cadre de la nouvelle pac d'activer
lisons des éléments de réponse pour ces
viticulteurs je t'aurais aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre que vous puissiez
me donner des réponses précises afin de
donner tout apaisement aux viticulteurs
qui m'interroge merci le président
monsieur le sénateur dufour voiliers et
ça fait écho aux autres questions qui
ont été posées
la réalité c'est que nos dispositifs des
10 ils ne sont pas grévistes à vis de la
situation
prenons la viticulture du gers il
s'avère que le dispositif des calamités
agricoles
il ne peut être déployé sur la
viticulture la ville ti culture n'est
pas éligible au moment où je vous parle
au dispositif des calamités agricoles
c'est ça la réalité et donc qu'est-ce
qu'il nous faut faire d'abord comme ça a
été dit il faut qu'on prenne des mesures
d'accompagnement social
parce que pour certains il ya des
questions de chômage partiel à la
demande du premier ministre est réunie
dès lundi une cellule de crise
interministérielle pour pouvoir déployer
déployer l'ensemble des mesures de crise
donc sociale évidemment financière là où
ça peut être avec l'origine calamités
agricoles
mais aller au delà avec ce fonds
exceptionnel qui doit permettre de
soutenir la viticulture notamment et ça
rend la chose là aussi plus complexe
mais il nous faut l'appréhender dans sa
complexité pour la viticulture c'est une
perte de revenus n'ont pas cette année
mais l'année suivante
là où pour les abricotiers c'est une
perte de revenus pas l'année suivante
mais dès cet été donc il nous faut en
plus imaginer un dispositif et nous
sommes aussi en train d'y travailler
avec eux olivier du soft qui permettent
de prendre la réalité des pertes de
revenus en fonction des moments où elles
sont censées où ils sont censés arriver
ses revenus donc des mesures sociales
des mesures de gestion de crise des
mesures additionnelles avec ce fonds
exceptionnel et vous avez tout à fait
raison monsieur le sénateur
cette mobilisation totale elle doit être
néral et donc lors de ce comité
interministériel que j'évoquais nous
avons mobilisé également les assureurs
pour faire en sorte que toutes les
polices d'assurance qui étaient déjà
prises par un certain nombre de
viticulteurs dans notre pays ça à peu
près un viticulteur sur 3 simplement
enfin quand même pour qu'elle soit
active et le plus rapidement possible
mais aussi les banques et j'ai une
pensée notamment pour les jeunes
agriculteurs jeunes viticulteurs jeunes
arboriculteurs qui comptent ils
s'installent où beaucoup de dettes et
donc nous travaillons avec les banques
pour qu'on puisse leur offrir par mon
des facilités dans le paiement des
intérêts et du capital de ses dettes
voilà des réponses très précises
monsieur le sénateur ceux du fonds vous
avez vous pouvez donner du temps sonné
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
précisions
néanmoins je vois que vous avez
aujourd'hui la prudence de ne pas vous à
gauche et sur les délais quand vous êtes
venu dans le gers au mois de janvier
dernier dans le cadre la grippe aviaire
vous avez annoncé les indemnisations
pour les éleveurs dans le délai d'une
quinzaine jours où il s'avère
qu'aujourd'hui trois mois après ils
n'ont rien touché
donc je pense que vous avez eu raison
d'être plus présent aujourd'hui la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
michel gréaume pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologie avaient la
parole mme cyr collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
veolia et suez ont annoncé avoir trouvé
un accord la bataille pour l'or bleu et
les déchets se termine dos par un
compromis de bon sens selon certains
cet accord préserverait l'intégrité de
suez sur le plan social et industriel
tout en lui permettant de se recentrer
sont les activités françaises de l'eau
et des déchets le nouveau suez devrait
détenus par des actionnaires sans doute
majoritairement français avec les fonds
meridian gardians et l'américain jp qui
doivent s'engager pour quatre ans à
maintenir l'emploi et les acquis sociaux
bref tout va bien le gouvernement se
félicite du transfert de la gestion du
service public de l'eau et de
l'assainissement de la gestion d'une
ressource naturelle fondamental au
profit d'acteurs qui n'ont ni le
savoir-faire ni les capacités
financières avec des engagements de
court terme sont là poids et les acquis
sociaux
qu'en sera-t-il dans quatre ans et quel
sera l'avenir de la recherche et du
développement filières d'excellence de
suez vous acceptez une nouvelle des
organisations industrielles et laissé se
mettre en place un monopole privé dans
un secteur aussi essentielle sans vous
inquiéter des conséquences pour les
collectivités locales et les usagers
monsieur le ministre quel engagement
ferme se reprit pour assurer la
pérennité des emplois et des activités
dans le nouveau suède
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
communistes de leye en charge l'école
publique vous chuchote vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée groen pardonnez moi mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs et c'était
pas de passer du temps avec vous et d'y
prendre plaisir mais pardonnez moi pour
ce lapsus quelques mots madame la
sénatrice pardonnez moi pour répondre à
votre question et vous dire que le
gouvernement se félicite de l'accord
intervenu après plusieurs mois
d'affrontements
nous nous en félicitons car l'accord qui
intervient répond aux attentes qui avait
exprimé par le chef du gouvernement lors
du début de cette opposition entre le
groupe veolia et groupe suez
nous voulions et le premier ministre
avait rappelé un accord qui est logique
industrielle une logique de souveraineté
qui soient respectueux la concurrence au
bénéfice des collectivités locales et
respectueux de l'emploi aujourd'hui avec
l'accord intervenu le 12 avril
ces critères sont remplis nous devons
désormais veiller à ce qu'ils soient
parfaitement respectée nous allons
pouvoir ou plutôt nous allons assister à
la création d'un leader mondial autour
de veolia avec 37 milliards d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires dans l'eau et dans
les déchets nous allons voir naître un
nouveau suez pour reprendre votre
expression dans l'eau et les déchets au
niveau français avec un chiffre
d'affaires prévisionnel de 7 milliards
d'euros
et comme vous l'avez vous même rappeler
des investisseurs majoritairement
français investisseurs de long terme ce
qui est gage de sécurité pour l'ensemble
de l'entreprise et des emplois le haut
veolia a réitéré sa volonté de tenir
l'intégralité des engagements sociaux
qui avaient été pris et là aussi nous
veillerons de manière extrêmement
attentive à ce que ces engagements
soient tenus et enfin cet accord
consacre aussi
un certain nombre de décisions notamment
l'arrêt des procédures en justice
l'arrêt de la cession accélérée des
actifs de suez ou encore la
désactivation du projet de fondation
néerlandaise
j'ajoute enfin je re cela répond à une
de vos interrogations une de vos
inquiétudes que le périmètre de suez du
nouveau suez reprend à nouveau votre
expression au niveau national est un
périmètre préserver ce qui garantit des
conditions de concurrence pour les
collectivités locales qui travaillent
avec ce groupe comme avec les autres
groupes en matière d'eau et de déchets
qui sont des conditions concurrence que
tout le monde attendait et que tout le
monde sollicités désormais cet accord de
têtes mises en oeuvre nous serons
attentifs à ces quatre points avec bruno
le maire est sous l'autorité du premier
ministre
le projet industriel la compétitivité la
préservation de l'emploi et la volonté
que pour les collectivités locales les
règles de concurrence soient respectées
car c'est aussi les conditions pour
accéder à un service au meilleur prix
monsieur le ministre ce n'est pas un
accord amiable c'est une trahison
trahison pour l'intersyndicale de suez
tenue totalement à l'écart des
négociations trahison de l'état qui n'a
plus prise sur ces entreprises
absolument stratégique
pourtant il ya urgence à garantir à
droit effectif alou ce que nous
proposerons demain dans l'hémicycle il
faut aider les collectivités qui veulent
rétablir la gestion de l'eau en régie et
rendent les premiers litres gratuit et
il faut maintenir l'emploi et les
filières d'excellence dans notre pays et
c'est tout ce que cette fusion
fragilisait la parole et l'autre
collègue julien bargeton vont le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant de la
parole monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à mains
de la miss de la culture d'abord
permettez-moi de vous saluer de vous
dire je pense au nom de tous les bancs
le plaisir
et l'honneur que nous avons à vous
retrouver
vraiment merci ça nous a ça nous fait
chaud au coeur
il y a deux ans jour pour jour presque
notre dame brûlés et les les cendres
sont encore bien présentes
cela a déclenché une émotion mondiale
la souscription annoncée par le
président de la république le soir même
à attirer les dons de 300000 particulier
de 6000 entreprises venues de 140 pays
dans le monde
dans le roman de victor hugo
l'archidiacre frollo refusent de prêter
de l'argent à son frère cadet qu'il aime
comme un fils parce qu'il a peur que ils
utilisent à mauvais escient et cette
question bien plus tard se pose
aujourd'hui quand la cour des comptes
nous alerte sur la transparence et la
traçabilité des dons qui sont faits je
sais la difficulté de la mission de
l'établissement public et je sais aussi
les fils cas si l'efficacité du
dispositif
madame la ministre pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur la transparence
deuxième question les fonds seront ils
suffisants quand nous savons que 165
millions ont d'ores et déjà été dépensés
en deux ans pour sécuriser l'édifice et
donc est ce que l'ensemble des fonds
nécessaires ne dépasserons t-il pas les
dons qu'ils ont pourtant afflué et enfin
troisième question l'engagement qui a
été pris de rouvrir la cathédrale pour
avril 2024 pourra-t-il être tenu je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est à l'honneur mais miss de la culture
ce président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur julien
bargeton permettez-moi d'abord de vous
remercier pour les très nombreux
témoignages de soutien qui me sont
num de tous les bancs de cette assemblée
croyez bien que j'en ai été profondément
touché
[Applaudissements]
monsieur sénateurs julien à barges temps
où souligné à juste titre l'émotion
considérable qui nous a saisi tous il y
a deux ans lors de l' incendie qui a
ravagé notre dame de paris
cette émotion a été considérable en
france et dans le monde entier et s'est
concrétisée par une souscription
publique qui a réuni 830 millions
d'euros de dons une somme totalement
inédite
je suis évidemment garante de la bonne
utilisation des fonds et de leur
transparence
c'est ainsi que dans ce cadre la cour
des comptes a émis un certain nombre de
préconisations que nous avons suivi et
même anticiper comme la comptabilité
analytique absolument indispensable pour
assurer cette parfaite transparence
il nous reste un point de divergence
avec la cour des comptes
en effet nous estimons que le
financement de l'établissement public de
notre dame de paris est absolument
indispensable de la bonne conduite des
travaux
il nous faut évidemment une maîtrise
d'ouvragé performante pour faire tout
cela
je signale au passage que nous avons
pris en charge le loyer bien entendu de
pardon du fait du bâtiment qui héberge
cette cet établissement public
alors il ya une débat qui est née
certains pensent qu' il y aura trop
d'argent et qu'il faut déjà penser à une
utilisation ultérieure
certains pensent au contraire qu'il en
aura pas assez je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle les sommes ainsi récoltées nous
permettent d'envisager tranquillement ce
chantier la sécurisation sera terminé à
la fin de l'été nous passerons à la
phase de l'art de restauration nous nous
rendrons d'ailleurs demain avec le
président de la république sur deux
chantiers
je peux vous dire monsieur le sénateur
quand 2024 la cathédrale notre dame de
paris sera réouverte
merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur bargeton vous aviez quelques
secondes
la parole est à notre collègue denis
bouad pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains vous avez la
parole
c'est le président chers collègues sur
ministre alors que la détresse
psychologique est toujours très présente
dans nos campagnes
les premiers ennuis avril fut au
dramatique pour bon nombre de paysans
français aujourd'hui la solidarité
nationale s'impose
les réponses qui seront apportées devant
ne laisser aucun agriculteur sur le côté
face à ce gel généralisé répondre à
l'urgence sur le terrain doit être notre
priorité
pour autant cela ne doit pas nous
empêcher d'apporter des solutions
pérennes pour inviter pour éviter ces
catastrophes économiques et humaines du
fait du dérèglement climatique ces aléas
le gel à gré de la sécheresse l'excès
d'eau que sais-je encore sont de plus en
plus fréquent est de plus en plus
intense alors que seulement 30% de la
ferme france est assurée monsieur le
ministre
le temps est venu de repenser
l'assurance récolte sur l'ensemble du
territoire
et bien entendu la rendre accessible à
tous nos agriculteurs pour cela il nous
faut baisser la franchise à 20% et
augmenter le niveau de subventions à 70%
comme le prévoit le règlement européen
omnibus d'autres propositions innovantes
pourraient être mises sur la table
je pense au pool de réassurance qui est
pratiqué en espagne et qui permet de
mutualiser les risques
dans son allocution du 12 mars 2000 avec
le président de la république déclaré le
délégué d'autres alimentation à d'autres
était une folie
alors oui protéger notre agriculture
c'est protéger notre souveraineté
c'est bien deux c'est bien là la place
et le rôle de l'état
je suis persuadé que comme pour les
cotations catastrophes naturelles les
français sont prêts à faire preuve de
solidarité pour défendre notre
agriculture et notre souveraineté
alimentaire en ce sens nos sioniste êtes
vous prêt à mettre sur la table
l'assurance récolte y compris sur les
sujets centraux que sont l'assurance
obligatoire mais aussi la réassurance e
d'état
pour vous répondre monsieur le ministre
de l'agriculture de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur oui moi je suis
tout à fait prêt le mettre sur la table
et pour tout vous dire ça fait deux mois
que je travaille déjà dessus
pardon pardon pardon de rentrer dans la
technicité de la chose mais vous l'avez
fait dans votre question en fait
aujourd'hui vous dites il ya notamment
des pistes d'amélioration qui le niveau
de franchise
aujourd'hui il est environ à 30 % et on
pourrait réglementairement le bessat 20%
mais également la part du budget
subventionnés dans le coup de la prime
d'assurance de la police d'assurance qui
est aujourd'hui subventionné à 60 5% et
qu'on pourrait passer à 70%
moi je suis totalement favorable mais la
question en fait elle n'est pas là la
question c'est qui paye ce surcoût c'est
ça la véritable question parce
qu'aujourd'hui les options qui sont sur
la table ses dires ce surcoût qui est
payé faut qu'on le fasse payer par la
politique agricole commune mais en fait
ça revient à quoi ça revient à dire
qu'on fait payer par le monde agricole
une assurance sur des risques qui en
fait ne sont pas assurables et donc la
véritable question
ces deux d'avoir l'humilité et le
courage de dire que ces éléments ces
événements climatiques ne peuvent être
assurées par simplement le monde
agricole que le monde agricole n'a pas
la capacité lui même de le faire quand
on parle d'une assurance voiture votre
assurance voiture le coût de l'assurance
voiture elles dépendent de votre
comportement qui était le vôtre et cinq
dernières années
quand on parle de l'assurance récolte le
coût de votre assurance récolte dépend
du climat qu'il a fait des cinq
dernières années
mais vous n'y êtes pour rien et donc la
véritable question qui nous est posée
mais qui est un véritable choix
démocratique parce que ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent c'est comment la solidarité
nationale doit elle entrer en ligne de
compte pour accompagner nos agriculteurs
face à des aléas climatiques dont ils
n'en n'ont pas la responsabilité mais
dont ils sont les premières victimes
je terminerai juste monsieur le sénateur
tout ça toute cette action résolue je
rebondis sur ce que disait le sénateur
dufourcq tout à l'heure quand vous dites
monsieur le sénateur qu'aucune n'a été
versée c'est strictement faux
strictement faux
donc le cas de la grippe aviaire
précisément parce que ce gouvernement a
décidé de faire des acomptes au 9 avril
on avait déjà onze millions cinq de
verser et 7 millions 5 en cours de
versement
donc on peut ne pas être d'accord sur
des choses mais de là à véhiculer des
suspicions alors qu'on essaye de faire
pousser les choses je trouve ça
scandaleux
donc c'est faux monsieur le ministre si
je partage une partie de vos propos
aujourd'hui quand même soyez conscients
que l'ensemble des agriculteurs français
vivent tous les jours dans l'angoissé
des aléas climatiques
aujourd'hui le risque climatique c'est
des plus hauts risques aléatoires c'est
un risque certain la parole est à mme la
présidente note rallye de la pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole le
président merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
l'hiver est violemment revenus brasero
bougies arrosage préventif les efforts
mis en oeuvre par les agriculteurs n'ont
pas suffi la viticulture mais aussi
l'arboriculture et le maraîchage et les
grandes cultures ont été dévastés des
parcelles jusque là épargnée par le plus
virulent ces épisodes de 2017 et de 1991
ont gelé en totalité les dégâts sont
immenses
avec le risque de recommencer dans les
jours à venir pour la viticulture il
s'ajoute à un contexte déjà
particulièrement compliqué pour la
filière au coeur de multiples crises
structurelles et conjoncturelles se
dessine le risque de disparition de ce
qui fait la france dans son patrimoine
ses paysages mais aussi dans les
fondements de son économie
pour toutes ces raisons monsieur le
ministre ce ne sont pas des mesures de
relance mais un véritable plan de
sauvetage de la filière vitivinicole
française qu'il vous faut mettre en
place à court terme à catastrophe
exceptionnelle aide exceptionnelle pour
recréer de la trésorerie en plus des
exonérations de charges et de taxes à
moyen terme différer de deux ans le
remboursement des pg e sur 20 ans de
mensualités mais à long terme il nous
faut surtout votre appui sur l'assurance
yale l'an dernier nous avions présenté
une proposition de résolution avec mes
collègues
yvon collin et henri cabanel vous devez
nous aider à finaliser ce travail face à
l'europe face aux assureurs
pour entre ce dispositif incontournable
il faut baisser le seuil de
déclenchement des pertes de rendement
augmenter le taux de subvention et
surtout revoir la méthode de calcul de
la base assurables fixé sur la moyenne
olympique par l'europe il ya plus d'un
an l'association nationale des élus de
la vigne et du vin était sur le point
d'organiser un grenelle de la
viticulture pour établir une stratégie
globale de filières en réunion
interministérielle
nous souhaitons leur lancée et comptons
sur votre soutien monsieur le ministre
l'urgence est réelle rassurer la filière
sur le long terme
je vous remercie on vous répondra par le
communiste de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation monsieur de normandie
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice de lettres d'abord
faudrait saluer mais on a l'occasion à
de multiples reprises d'en discuter
ensemble tout votre engagement et celui
de vos collègues sur le soutien à ce
beau secteur vini viticole
vous l'avez dit l'année qu'on vient de
vivre a été en tout point dramatique
pour le secteur
viticole je crois pouvoir dire que
lorsqu il a fallu mettre en place un
certain nombre de dettes d'appui
notamment qu'ovide ce gouvernement a
répondu présent je me souviens l'un des
premier déplacement du nouveau premier
ministre jean castex était précisément
auprès de la filière viticole où nous
avions annoncé un renforcement des aides
l'autre élément et c'est peut-être le
seul moment de lueur d'espoir que nous
avons vécu ces dernières ces derniers
mois dans ce secteur là c'est grâce à
l'action diplomatique
la levée en tout cas le moratoire des
fameuses taxes trump qui impacte et là
aussi la filière et oui il nous faut
pour la filière viti vini viticole avoir
des actions de court terme forte
notamment sur le social le point vous
évoquez sur les pelles les pg e pardon
est très important et nous sommes en
train d'en discuter avec les
représentants de la filière mais
également sur le long terme parce que de
manière générale dans notre pays il n'y
a pas plus de trois viticulteurs sur dix
qui sont assurées pas plus et non pas
parce que les sept autres serait
irresponsable comme parfois il est dit
pas du tout tout simplement parce que
les conditions d'accès à l'assurance ne
sont plus à même d'être accessible aux
viticulteurs lui-même alors vous avez
parlé de plusieurs sujets des franchises
je l'évoquais tout à l'heure de la
question du montant d'indemnisation mais
également de cette fameuse moyenne
olympiques et c'est quoi le drame sur
lequel repose aujourd'hui nos
dispositifs c'est qu'en fait on fait la
moyenne le plus généralement des cinq
dernières années à quel on enlève la
première la meilleure et la moins bonne
est donc en fait on voit que le montant
à indemniser s'étiole d'années après
année et donc on est plus intéressant si
tous acquis douanes qui doit être revue
mais encore une fois moi je pense que ça
ne peut pas être revu à l'aune du seul
monde agricole
il faut que la solidarité nationale
s'empare aussi de là tu nous avais
quelques secondes longue
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
anne vantal ont pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture
monsieur le ministre vous avez
parfaitement décrit la dimension
historique de la catastrophe agricoles
provoqués par le gène en ardèche où vous
vous êtes rendu avec le premier ministre
la vigne les apports fruitiers et en
particulier les cerises et les abricots
accusent des pertes allant de 90 à 100 %
vous avez déclaré qu'à situation
exceptionnelle moyen exceptionnel
et bien soit le gouvernement doit donc
ording organiser la solidarité nationale
en s'écartant du schéma classique que
nos agriculteurs ne connaissent que trop
et qui se caractérise par son cortège de
lenteur de tracasseries et d'injustice
la france qui en temps de crise c'est
sauvegarder ses banques
en quelques jours ou nationaliser ces
entreprises stratégiques peut et doit
sauver du désastre ce qui la nourrissent
c'est pourquoi je souhaite vous
interroger sur le caractère exceptionnel
de l'action de l'état concernant
l'inclusion de toutes les filières
frappé notamment la viticulture sur la
simplicité des démarches que les
exploitants devront effectuer et surtout
sur la rapidité des indemnisations
monsieur le ministre les trésoreries des
exploitations ont été prouvés par la
sécheresse et 2020 les taxes américaines
sur le verre et la crise du coc vide
allez-vous pour la survie de nos
filières engagé cette course contre leur
mort économique
les alimentations que le président
sénatrice pantalon oui oui et archi oui
et je ne cesse de le faire sous
l'autorité du premier ministre avec le
ministre olivier dussopt pts avec qui
nous étions en ardèche ces derniers
jours oui parce que nous le devons nous
le devons à notre monde paysan nous le
devons à celles et ceux qui nous
nourrissent nous le devons à toutes
celles et ceux qui se sont battus avec
beaucoup de force contre cette vague de
froid
donc oui non seulement nous nous leur
devons mais en plus nous allons le faire
et encore une fois de manière très
précise nous allons il nous l'avons déjà
fait enclenchez tous les dispositifs de
crise que ce soit sur le volet social
que ce soit sur le volet assurantielle
que soit sur le volet calamités
agricoles
mais je ne peux pas être plus clair
aujourd'hui ces dispositifs de crise ne
sont pas gré ne sont pas agréés et ne
sont pas opérationnels pour faire face à
l'ampleur de ce qui s'est passé et c'est
pour ça qu'on est en place un fonds
exceptionnel qu'on veut le plus simple
possible
en fait fondés sur les dispositifs que
ce gouvernement a mis en place dans le
cadre de la crise de l'aco vide et je
crois que tout le monde peut s'accorder
pour dire que les dispositifs financiers
mis en place dans le cadre de la crise
de l'aco vides ont été d'une simplicité
d'un pragmatisme et d'une réalité que
beaucoup de pays européens nous envient
beaucoup
donc oui nous leur devons oui nous
sommes à la tâche oui nous avons
impliqué l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de l'assureur en passant par
le banquier tous les ministères et
toutes les filières pour apporter les
aides au moment où les agriculteurs en
ont besoin à très court terme ils en ont
besoin par exemple sur le sujet social
sur le sujet chômage partiel sur le
sujet des intérêts d'emprunt du moment
dans la viticulture
la question c'est une perte de revenus
qui arrive en 2022 dans la viticulture
au delà du premier point que je viens
d'évoquer dans l'arboriculture ça arrive
tout de suite dans la grande culture on
en parlait avec le président tout à
l'heure où ça a été aussi des drames il
ya à peu près de 10 à 20% de la
seulement de betteraves qui a cramé en
l'espace de quelques jours
la question c'est comment on accompagne
pour ressemer par exemple voilà et donc
c'est tout ça que nous faisons nous
sommes à la tâche et nous faisons avec
beaucoup de détermination
encore une fois nous leur devons
un avantage je croirais pts mais
j'insiste vraiment monsieur le ministre
sur la rapidité des aides
pourquoi en ardèche certains
agriculteurs qui ont été touchés par la
grêle de 2019 n'ont à ce jour toujours
pas été indemnisés donc donc les emplois
agricoles notamment les saisonniers mais
ces exploitations et les exploitations
ne survivront pas à cette inertie
monsieur le ministre il est temps de
proclamer l'état d'urgence agricole
la parole est à d'autres collègues jean
luc fichet pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine avec la merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
de nombreux professionnels nous alerte
sur les souffrances psychologiques et
psychiques éprouvé par un grand nombre
d'enfants et d'adolescents de notre pays
ces jeunes subissent en effet de plein
fouet les effets directs et indirects de
la crise sanitaire
ceci s'ajoutant parfois un contexte
familial déjà compliqué ou qui s'est
détériorée suite aux périodes de
confinement face à ces situations
préoccupantes
nous constatons l'impossibilité actuelle
de répondre à ces nombreuses situations
de détresse
faute de moyens suffisants pour faire
face à l'augmentation des demandes des
centres médico psychologiques qui sont
saturés une pénurie de lits
d'hospitalisation à temps complet un
manque d'effectifs de pédopsychiatres la
liste des carences s'allonger inquiète
l'ensemble de ces insuffisances
structurelles entraîne une discrète
unité voire de graves défaillances dans
les prises en charge individuelle
laissant les professionnels sociaux et
médico-sociaux bien seul face à des
situations qui nécessitent pourtant un
accompagnement renforcé et surtout
pluridisciplinaire madame la ministre
chaque jour nous voyons de nouvelles
formes de souffrance psychique se
développer chez des enfants et
adolescents de plus en plus jeunes
violence addiction tentative de suicide
le risque de nouveaux passages à l'acte
ne cesse de s'amplifier
quelles mesures concrètes et urgentes
le gouvernement compte-t-il mettre en
place pour parer à cette détresse est
grandissante de nos jeunes en
particulier pour les plus fragiles
d'entre eux je vous remercie pour
répondre à temps dans les tavernes amis
délégués en charge de l'économie mal à
mourinho merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur jean luc fichet la
psychiatrie infantile vous le savez
souffre de difficultés structurelles
bien connu depuis de nombreuses années
ça ne date malheureusement pas ni de
cette mandature ni même de la crise
sanitaire les départs à la retraite des
effectifs médicaux spécialisés
l'augmentation sensible de la demande en
soins ont suscité les situations de
saturation exacerbées par la crise
sanitaire en cours
c'est un enjeu qui préoccupe pleinement
le gouvernement si peu de données
consolidées existe beaucoup de signes
nous alertent évidemment les troubles du
sommeil des pressions et tentatives de
suicides que vous évoquez les pouvoirs
publics sont pleinement mobilisés autour
de franck bellivier délégué ministériel
à la santé mentale et psychiatrie et
d'adriers attaque et secrétaires d'état
en contact permanent avec les
professionnels médico sociaux pour
développer les mesures adaptées
personnel d'ailleurs auquel je tiens à
rendre hommage monsieur parce que vous
me le permettez aujourd'hui et notamment
les éducateurs spécialisés
nous avons réaffirmé dans la stratégie
nationale de santé à travers la feuille
de route santé mentale et psychiatrie
toute l'attention particulière portée
notamment à la pédopsychiatrie les
enfants les adolescents également le 14
janvier dernier le président de la
république s'est entretenu avec les
pédopsychiatres sur cette dégradation le
constat a été dressé d'une forte
pression
une hausse moyenne de 40% des recours
aux urgences pour troubles de
comportement ce constat a conduit à
maintenir ouvertes d'ailleurs les écoles
les structures de la petite enfance pour
veiller à la dimension le docteur angèle
consoli pédopsychiatre à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière a été nommé au conseil
scientifique pour assurer la prise en
compte de l'impact des mesures considéré
sur les enfants cet après midi le chef
de l'état se rendra à reims
accompagné des ministres olivier ferrand
et adrien attaqué au service de
psychiatrie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent pourrait changer notamment
avec les familles les professionnels du
service de pédopsychiatrie qui
travaillent et recueillir évidemment
leur retour d'expérience ce déplacement
permettra également de revenir sur les
chantiers en cours pour répondre face à
l'urgence comme de manière structurelle
aux attentes de ce secteur clé parole
oui merci madame la ministre mais
malheureusement je crains que vous
n'ayez pas répondu à ma question
on efface affectivement un secteur qui
est en grande souffrance et je sais que
cet après midi le président de la
république visite un établissement de
pédopsychiatrie j'espère qu'il prendra
conscience de l'urgence à agir car la
souffrance est grande chez nos jeunes et
y compris les jeunes qui ont des
difficultés sociales et parfois
physiques merci merci la parole est
maintenant à monsieur le questeur
philippe bas pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
et je voudrais vous interpeller sur le
fonctionnement actuel du conseil des
ministres c'est l'organe constitutionnel
de la délibération gouvernementale or en
ce temps de crise sanitaire
il n'est plus réunies à l'elysée mais
remplacé par une réunion à distance
cela pose trois problèmes un problème
institutionnel la collégialité de la
délibération gouvernementale n'est pas
assurée dans les formes constitutionnel
et cela crée pour l'avenir un précédent
préoccupant un problème pour le respect
du secret des délibérations exposés à
des défaillances du cryptage ou à la
présence du deux tiers auprès des
ministres réunis à distance et enfin un
problème juridique
d'une part parce que le conseil
constitutionnel n'admet pas sans
conditions la validité des délibérations
à distance il s'est prononcé récemment à
l'égard du règlement de l'assemblée
et d'autre part parce que le conseil
constitutionnel censure
depuis 2003 la loi qui n'a pas été
délibéré correctement en conseil des
ministres avant son examen par le
parlement et dans ces conditions
monsieur le premier ministre
allez-vous demander au président de la
république de rétablir le fonctionnement
normal du conseil des ministres merci on
vous répondra par an le cas monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le questeur philippe bas je
dois vous avouer que je ne serais pas
imaginée en pleine crise sanitaire avoir
un répondre à ce type de questionnement
mais je vais tenter de me envoyé et je
vais tenter de me employés dans le
respect ou dans notre cas l'objectif du
respect des normes sanitaires le nombre
de membres du gouvernement assistent en
en présentiel comme on dit au conseil
des ministres a en effet été limités
depuis le début de la crise il s'agit là
d' appliquer une exigence qui s'applique
à toutes les réunions dans la sphère
administrative et au delà le conseil des
ministres vous le savez est un organe
collégial dont les modalités
d'organisation ne sont pas définis par
les textes
la seule exigence vous l'avez rappelé
posés par la constitution est d'assurer
que ce conseil est bien en mesure
d'exercer les attributions que la
constitution lui confie délibérer sur
les projets de lois c'est l'article 39
délibérer sur les projets d'ordonnancé
l'article 38 sur certains projets de
décret c'est l'article 13 ainsi que de
pourvoir au plus aux emplois publics
mentionnées à l'article 13 de la
constitution
la notion de délibération renvoie à la
possibilité d'un échange de vues et de
prise de parole des membres du conseil
des ministres pour considérer que le
conseil des ministres a été valablement
réunis il convient donc non pas
d'examiner s'il a donné lieu
à une réunion physique de ses membres
mais si les modalités d'organisation lui
sont effectivement permis de délibéré et
c'est bien j'en atteste ce qui se passe
à cet effet il est fait recours
un dispositif de visioconférence porté
par un système sécurisé de niveau
confidentiel défense
conçue et opérés par l'état qui permet
une parfaite qualité et confidentialité
des échanges
vous voilà je l'espère monsieur le
questeur rassurer nous savons tous ici
vos grandes compétences juridiques que
je salue et votre grande révérence pour
la règle de droit mais déjà mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs il ya plus de
vingt siècles
cicéron appelez notre attention sur les
excès de cette révérence ce jus ce
schéma injuria monsieur le questeur
philippe bas en français
j'apprécie monsieur le premier ministre
que vous vous soyez donner le mal de me
répondre personnellement mais je
voudrais vous dire avec la plus grande
solennité que l'argument sanitaire ne
tient pas d'ailleurs vous ne seriez pas
ici pour nous répondre
si nous appliquions la même règle que
celle que vous prétendez voir s'opposer
au conseil des ministres et pourtant
votre sécurité sanitaire comme celle des
membres du gouvernement est assurée
aussi bien à l'assemblée nationale que
au sénat l'elysée dispose à l'évidence
de salles qui ont la dimension
nécessaire pour rire pour assurer la
sécurité sanitaire des ministres vous ne
devez plus prendre le risque de dégrader
voire de dénaturer les conditions de
délibérations et d'adoption des textes
et des nominations en conseil des
ministres vous prenez un grand risque
la parole et anne hélène françois belot
pour le groupe de l'union centriste la
parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre des affaires étrangères la
liberté des autres étant la mienne à
l'infini en birmanie or une sangle sushi
est sous le coup de nouvelles poursuites
pénales
depuis le coup d'état qui l'a chassé du
pouvoir le 1er février
la situation ne cesse de se dégrader
plus de 700 civils ont été tués par une
junte mortifère est de plus en plus
organisée le culte impressionnant la
personnalité se renforce autour du chef
avec des défilés militaires dignes des
plus grands régimes autoritaires
ce qui conforte l'armée dans son action
et fait croître la répression sanglante
des manifestations
désormais les militaires n'hésitent plus
à tuer jeunes ou moins jeunes pacifistes
ou militants ces hommes et ces femmes
qui lutté héroïquement pour leur liberté
sont abattus par des snipers une preuve
de plus s'il en fallait de cette
répression criminelle est intolérable
ce week-end encore 82 personnes ont
perdu la vie
l'ambassadrice de l'onu venus
spécialement n'a pas été autorisé à
rentrer dans le pays
la communauté internationale appelle une
nouvelle fois à s'affirmer en raison des
veto russe et chinois dong fang sushi
est détenu dans un lieu secret
six chefs d'accusation sont retenus
contre elle dont celui de corruption qui
pourrait l'empêcher d'exercer toute
fonction publique
monsieur le ministre face à ceux ci à ce
silence total est assourdissant la
france pays des droits de l'homme ne
peut pas rester sans rien dire la
non-reconnaissance de la jeanne par
l'état français n'est pas bi plus
suffisante
l'union européenne doit aussi s'imposer
et répondre d'une seule voix les vétos
de l'onu ne sont pas des raisons
acceptable pour laisser de tels crimes
impunis
nous devons agir quelle sanction allez
vous prendre pour enrayer cette tragédie
qu'endurent les birmans désespérément
seuls face à leurs tortionnaires
pour vous répondre à la parole et au
secrétaire d'état en charge des français
de l'étranger la francophonie jean
baptiste lemoyne
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur françois bonneau
par une demande d'excusés en premier
lieu jean yves le drian est actuellement
en inde pour mener un certain nombre de
consultations dans l'espace indo
pacifique et plus de deux mois après le
coup d'état commis par les forces armées
vous l'avez rappelé la situation demeure
extrêmement critique
on en est aujourd'hui dans un décompte
qui est hélas macabre à 710 personnes
tuées trois mille personnes arrêtées
dont le président de la république winje
la conseillère d'état
donc ce qui vous l'avez rappelé et face
à cela il ne s'agit pas seulement de
condamner il s'agit comme vous le faites
en nous appelant à l'action et bien
d'agir et nous avons d'ores et déjà agi
avec nos partenaires européens depuis le
22 mars
onze personnes responsables du coup
d'état dont le commandant en chef des
forces de sécurité son adjointe qui ont
sont sous le coup maintenant de
sanctions et de mesures restrictives
avec les européens nous travaillons à de
nouvelles mesures de sanction sur des
individus et nous espérons pouvoir
aboutir dès le 19 avril c'est demain
lors du prochain conseil des affaires
étrangères nous avons également suspendu
tout soutien budgétaire aux programmes
gouvernementaux qui sont désormais aux
mains des militaires
et il ne faut pas s'interdire de
regarder également en europe et un
incertain de préférences commerciales
parce que eh bien nous sommes attaché à
ses valeurs comme vous le signalez nous
maintenons l'action humanitaire en
revanche parce que la société civile
elle ne doit pas être pénalisés et nous
encourageons et bien toutes les
démarches qui sont faites à l'eau à
l'échelon régional avec l'asian un
sommet doit se réunir dans les tout
prochains jours mais également au niveau
des nations unies puisque nous avons
soutenu fortement la consultation menée
la semaine dernière avec d'ailleurs des
représentants de l'opposition
donc nous sommes à l'action à la tâche
et naturellement en prenant des
décisions à chaque fois contre ce régime
qui tirent contre son peuple ce qui est
naturellement inacceptable doigt et
dénoncés mais surtout doit être
condamnée dans les faits
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue s'était fall
le rudulier pour le groupe des
républicains
merci monsieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le président de la
république le 7 avril dernier s'est
adressé aux 3,5 millions de français de
l'étranger à travers un courrier et ce
de manière purement fortuite au
lendemain même des dépôt des listes pour
les élections consulaires du mois de mai
alors loin de moi l'idée de nier au
président de la république le droit
d'écrire à ses compatriotes de
l'étranger mais il est évident à la
lecture de ce courrier que le président
a hélas confondues communication
institutionnelle et communication
politique de surcroît en utilisant une
base de données exclusivement réservés à
des finalités administrative
contrairement à la liste électorale
consulaire
ceci est moralement condamnable et
politiquement déloyale moralement
condamnable car l'utilisation d'un
registre à des fins électoralistes
constitue une violation par le président
de la république lui-même d'un principe
essentiel en démocratie qui est
l'égalité de traitement entre les
candidats et politiquement déloyale
parce que cette correspondance
parsemer d'autosatisfaction s'apparente
à un plaidoyer en faveur des candidats
et les oem pour les futures élections
alors monsieur le ministre comment
pouvez-vous justifier l'utilisation de
moyens étatiques à des fins de
propagande à un moment électoral clé
pour les français établis hors de france
pour joindre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état en charge des français de
l'étranger et de la francophonie
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur écoutez
vous me donnez l'occasion de vous faire
un aveu oui le président de la
république est particulièrement attentif
à la situation des français établis hors
de france
oui le président de la république les
considère comme des français à part
entière et pas des français à part tout
court
et permettez moi de relever que dans ce
courrier le président de la république
d'ailleurs salue l'action de l'ensemble
des élus des français de l'étranger
les élus locaux mais également les
parlementaires qui siègent tissi et le
président la république vous savez il
s'est pas contenté d'une lettre
pardonnez moi mais c'est plutôt même des
chiffres et des lettres des chiffres des
chiffres 220 220 millions d'euros c'est
le montant du plan de soutien
exceptionnelles mises en oeuvre pour
justement accompagner les français
établis hors de france depuis le début
de la pandémie pour pouvoir les
accompagner d'un point de vue social
avec l'aide des sceaux escaut vide pour
pouvoir les accompagner en matière
éducative avec des bourses pour pouvoir
les accompagner en matière médicale des
postes d'oxygénothérapie déployés dans
80 postes 1 et donc
n'oublions pas les 370 mille français de
passage qui ont été rapatriés est aussi
une très grande solidarité qui a joué et
donc le président de la république eh
bien c'est une première il s'est adressé
directement aux français de l'étranger
mais il ya déjà quelques années et
c'était déjà une première le président
de la république s'est adressé
directement à l'assemblée des français
de l'étranger
monsieur le sénateur je crains que vous
ne deviez vous habituer à quelques
premières
monsieur le rudulier quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre vous m'avez pas
convaincu par rapport à votre réponse et
ça sera le cas échéant juge de
l'élection au conseil d'état de se
positionner pour savoir si vos
agissements ont altéré la sincérité du
scrutin
la parole est à notre collègue à la
michel meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
indispensable essentiel applaudi à 20
heures il y a un an nous ne tarit sion
pas d'éloges pour saluer l'engagement
des professionnels du soin à l'hôpital
et dans les ehpad en juillet 2020 les
conclusions du ségur de la santé accès
une revalorisation salariale pour les
agents hospitaliers laissant de côté
nombre d'agents exerçant pourtant les
mêmes métiers dans les établissements du
secteur social et médico-social les
oubliés du ségur ont dû bataillé de
longs mois pour faire entendre cette
injustice et arracher une juste
reconnaissance une revalorisation
mérités de leur rémunération
ils et elles ont eu raison de se
mobiliser notamment les professionnels
du soin à domicile dont nous souhaitons
le développement vos annonces madame la
ministre lundi pense laisse à penser que
cet oubli serait réparé s'il faut se
satisfaire que votre gouvernement
s'engage enfin à ouvrir cette
revalorisation au personnel paramédical
sans distinction du statut de leur
employeur
si nous saluons la revalorisation
étendue aux personnels éducatifs du
secteur du handicap
de nombreuses incertitudes demeurent
quelle revalorisation prévoyez-vous pour
les nouveaux oublier les professionnels
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
réalisant les mêmes tâches éducatives
sanitaires ou social les travailleurs
sociaux des foyers d'accueil médical
10 et des instituts médico-éducatifs
pourtant aussi essentielle aux personnes
en situation de handicap
des psychologues dans les hôpitaux des
sages-femmes professions médicales
toujours sous valorisé les infirmiers
anesthésistes
madame la ministre comment
envisagez-vous sérieusement de financer
ses promesses si vous repoussez encore
la discussion parlementaire sur les
moyens accordés aux grands âges et à
l'autonomie allez vous envoyer la
facture au département merci madame la
sénatrice michel meunier
je connais parfaitement votre engagement
de longue date et votre connaissance de
ce secteur sanitaire et médico-social et
vous comprenez donc qu'il est essentiel
avant de parler de ces professionnels un
patient légitime du ségur hainaut
n'oubliez de rappeler le chemin parcouru
depuis le mois de juillet dernier
je pense que vous conviendrez déjà que
la marche était grande
elle est franchie nous continuons
d'avancer plus de 9 milliards d'euros
sont d'ores et déjà mobilisés pour
permettre à 1.5 million de
professionnels en établissement et en
ehpad d'être valorisé entre 160 et 180 5
euros par mois
détendre aussi est revalorisé
l'indemnité de service public
exclusif les indemnités de stage aussi
pour les internes
les étudiants de santé et paramédicaux
sont également revalorisée 500 mille
professionnels de santé paramédicaux
sont concernés pour près de 740 millions
d'euros ce n'est pas rien et il ne
faudrait pas je le crois en atténuer la
portée pour les aides soignants par
exemple en poids physique emplois
exigeant jusqu'ici peu reconnu après un
an de carrière ils passeront d'un
salaire de 1532 à 1760 euros nets ce
n'est pas négligeable vous en
conviendrez
cette revalorisation s'échelonnent tout
au long de la carrière jusqu'à son terme
ces professionnels qui pouvaient
jusqu'ici prétendre à une retraite
prétendre aujourd'hui à 2300 environ net
pourront demain prétendre à 2954 net
soit près de 3000 euros
je crois que pour connaître ces
professionnels et les entendre sur le
terrain c'est essentiel mérité cet
historique et le reconnaissent alors
madame la sénatrice je comprends que les
professionnels médico-sociaux dans les
négociations se poursuivent
puisse être impatient mais ils ne sont
en rien oublié ils ne sont oubliés ni
dans notre quotidien
ni dans notre travail de revalorisation
en cours les ministres jacqueline
gourault et amélie de montchalin ainsi
que michel laforcade dans sa mission
poursuivre chacune et chacun des
discussions avec les professionnels
concernés
si la situation est aussi exacerbé
aujourd'hui c'est précisément parce
qu'aucune réponse de cette nature ne
leur avait apporté ces dix dernières
années et vous en conviendrez avec moi
la parole est maintenant ne peut que les
quatre îles pro cassia pour le groupe
est républicain apparu merci monsieur le
président madame la secrétaire d'état
plusieurs de mes collègues sont
intervenus la semaine dernière sur
l'aide publique accordée à air france je
souhaite pour ma part aujourd'hui vous
interroger sur le choix du repreneur des
18 créneau que la compagnie leur a cédé
à andy pour respecter les règles de
concurrence
monsieur jay marie à abstrait la semaine
dernière que le gouvernement éviterait
tout dumping social ou fiscal
mais rien n'a été dit sur les critères
environnementaux
rien n'empêche des compagnies low cost
de candidater c'est d'ailleurs ce que
visait à la commission européenne en
disant je cite que cette cession devrait
se faire au bénéfice du consommateur
je n'ai rien contre les compagnies low
cost mais certaines n'utilisent qu'un
seul type galion souvent anciens pour
minimiser les frais d'entretien
ces avions sont plus polluants et plus
bruyants
il ne faudrait pas d'un côté imposé air
france d'être plus attentive à
l'environnement et à la force et à
innover ce qui est une des conditions de
l'aide publique
et le lot de permettre à ces concurrents
low cost ou non d'opérer à sa place sur
notre territoire avec des avions plus
polluants plusieurs villes du val de
marne comme villeneuve le roi villeneuve
saint georges à blond ou en lice se
plaignent depuis des années des
pollutions dit à l'aéroport
sachez que ni les élus ni les
parlementaires ni les riverains
n'accepterons que la réattribution des
créneaux aggrave la situation puisque le
ministère des transports siège au
conseil d'administration de
l'association pour la coordination des
horaires pouvez-vous m'assurer que le
gouvernement veillera à ce que ce choix
respecte les critères environnementaux
essentiel pour répondre
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état en charge de la biodiversité vers
la barre de la parole merci merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice
procaccia effectivement vous le savez ce
secteur aérien il a été durement touché
par la crise sanitaire en 2020 nous
observons une baisse de près de 70% du
trafic et une reprise n'est pas attendue
malheureusement avant quelques années
des chaînes de production ont également
dû être momentanément arrêté ou au
ralenti et l'état a répondu présent avec
des aides absolument sans précédent une
aide de 7 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis et d' avance d'actionnaire de
l'etat en échange de contreparties
environnemental et industriel tel que la
réorganisation de son réseau domestique
et les échanges sont nombreux à
l'assemblée dans le cadre du projet de
loi climat sur ce point ils arriveront
dans quelques jours au sénat ces
échanges menés par les ministres des
transports et de l'économie des finances
et de la relance avec la commission
européenne ont permis effectivement
d'aboutir à un accord le 6 avril dernier
un accord qui prévoit
18 créneau qui seront libérés par la
compagnie aérienne à l'aéroport paris
orly
nous avons veillé à ce que cela ne
vienne pas fragiliser air france d'abord
et ne compromettent pas sa
réorganisation notamment par rapport au
développement de l'activité de transavia
cet accord il prévoit que le
bénéficiaire des créneaux qui seront mis
à disposition de façon pérenne par air
france base ses avions équipage lié à
orly respectent pleinement le droit du
travail européen et national
les autorités françaises elles se sont
attachés à prévoir un mécanisme de
contrôle qui permettra de sanctionner
les éventuels manquements à cette cause
de conditions et le choix du repreneur
des lignes fera l'objet d'une
approbation par la commission européenne
parmi les compagnies qui m'a 9
manifesteront leur leurs intérêts alors
lors de ces négociations je vous
confirme avec la commission que nous
avons été très vigilants à ce que la
solution retenue ne provoque en aucun
cas une aggravation en termes de
nuisances sonores ou environnementale
pour les riverains de l'aéroport est par
ailleurs le plafonnement des mouvements
et le couvre-feu demeure inchangé je
remercie
progressium merci vous ne me confirmer
pas que l'accord prévoie explicitement
qu'il n'y aura pas des avions plus plus
loin vous m'avez vous nous avez répondu
à au même niveau alors je ne comprends
pas en imposant toutes les contraintes
qu'on impose aux aéroports et aux
compagnies aériennes françaises
qu'on n'essaie pas en attribuant de
nouveaux créneaux de faire mieux c'est
totalement contraire à la politique soit
disant environnementale que vous essayez
en ce moment d'imposer au secteur aérien
merci la parole et vatan notre collègue
je suis de guidel pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre déléguée auprès auprès du
ministre de la santé elle porte la
rémunération des professionnels de santé
actuellement engagé dans la campagne de
vaccination tout travail mérite salaire
il aura pourtant fallu trois mois pour
qu'enfin le travail du personnel de
santé notamment des retraités
intervenant dans les centres de
vaccination qu'ovide soient reconnus une
clarification bienvenue mais très
tardive et des mesures actées qui se
sont malheureusement pas encore entrée
en vigueur depuis janvier ce personnel
se bat pour obtenir une reconnaissance
et une rémunération de leurs heures
effectuées au centre de vaccination
certains personnels de santé attendent
toujours la rémunération de la vacation
au service au chili par leur apporter
une solution à partir du 1er avril
la rémunération est assurée par
l'assurance maladie pour le personnel de
santé pour les retraités sans activité
libérale cependant de leur côté les
infirmiers retraités n'ont rien obtenu
jusqu'à présent et commence à se
décourager
alors que le nombre de vaccination
augmente considérablement et que nous
avons vraiment besoin d'eux les ars et
des centres de vaccination continue à se
renvoyer la balle
en ce qui concerne la rémunération de
nombreuses questions restent donc que
sans réponse
les cotisations sociales saptel pour les
retraités comment procédez-vous au
remboursement des structures qui ont
avancé la rémunération de leur personnel
quelle plateforme mettrez-vous en place
qui soit efficace à long terme
enfin que comptez-vous faire madame
l'année nice pour accélérer la
rémunération des personnels de santé
retraités engagé dans la campagne de
vaccination coville je vous remercie
la ministre déléguée en charge le tout
le monde à bourguignon
si madame la sénatrice jocelyne guider
votre question est double je vais tâcher
de répondre à chacune de ces dimensions
ce qui concerne la mobilisation
exceptionnelle des professionnels de
santé retraité je crois qu'elle est à
l'image de la solidarité qui s'est
développé dans notre pays de manière
spontanée et je tiens à rendre hommage à
ce dévouement à cette mobilisation qui
nous permet précisément de renforcer nos
centres de vaccination sur le territoire
et qui se développe dans tout le pays
naturellement fusse-t-il retraités tout
travail
merritt rétribution vous avez raison il
face à l'urgence il était nécessaire de
mettre en oeuvre rapidement les
modalités les plus efficaces et les plus
adaptées pour verser leur salaire à ces
professionnels c'est désormais chose
faite sachez-le puisque le paiement
direct des buts depuis le 1er avril 2021
y compris pour les vacations passé c'est
à dire de manière rétroactive
cette rémunération est assurée par la
cepam évidemment et bien qu'ils y soient
déjà invité vous pouvez relayer cette
invitation ce qu'ils se rapprochent de
leurs caisses
à cette fin l'immatriculation et les
obligations sociales sont assurés pour
leurs comptes par les urssaf sans aucune
démarche à effectuer
cela concerne les professionnels
retraités que vous mentionnez mais aussi
les étudiants les remplaçants
intervenant à titre exclusif ainsi que
les professionnels exerçant sur des
lieux non conventionnés avec leur centre
habituel de rattachement une solution
est donc à portée
nous avons vérifié dans les meilleurs
délais pour ces professionnels enfin ce
qui concerne la situation vous en
parliez sur le nombre de doses dans
certains centres de vaccination
la situation dont vous me faites par a
tendance à se réguler pour plusieurs
raisons le nombre de doses disponibles
augmentent notamment dans votre
département et de 5000 dose hebdomadaire
disponible dans l'essonne début janvier
nous avons atteint près de 21 mille 500
doses cette seule semaine
donc le deuxième point est relatif au
statut aussi de certains centres qui
disposent parfois d'un nombre de doses
plus restreinte
les ars veille donc à ce que cette
ventilation soit plus homogène pour
limiter le plus possible le type de
situation que vous évoquez ces
difficultés devraient disparaître
progressivement dans les prochaines
semaines je vous remercie
alors voilà mon village madame les 10 ou
devons pas avoir les mêmes
renseignements parce que moi je peux
vous dire que le cpa même dans notre
département pour les cas aujourd'hui
n'ont pas remboursé les infirmières
auraient traité ça je peux vous le dire
vous avez bien compris que je fais
remonter ça enfin un coup de gueule mais
aussi une lassitude du personnel de
santé retraités qui en plus de ne pas
être rémunéré aujourd'hui se déplace
dans des centres de vaccination mobile
éloignés de leur lieu d'habitation alors
que le nombre de vaccins aujourd'hui
n'est pas au rendez vous en tous les cas
pas chez nous merci ma chère collègue
[Applaudissements]
nos prochaines questions d'actualité
auront lieu
le shaq mai 2021
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
sera reprise à 16h30 pour la déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat et
d'un vote sur cette déclaration
en application de l'article 53 de la
constitution relatives à l'organisation
des prochaines élections départementales
et régionales
la séance est donc suspendu
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat beaucoup de
sur deux sujets ont été abordés
notamment la vague de gel qui frappe les
cultures françaises
on va commencer le débrief de cette
séance de questions d'actualité et on va
aller en salle des conférences du sénat
retrouver steve jourdain qui est avec et
bien jean baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire
d'état chargé du tourisme pour parler
notamment et bien de la réouverture des
lieux touristiques et culturels oui jean
baptiste lemoyne bonjour demain emmanuel
macron va présider va présider bien une
réunion consacrée au calendrier la
réouverture des lieux recevant du public
vous allez y participer personnellement
oui tout à fait c'est la deuxième
réunion que le chef de l'état justement
fait sur cette thématique
la première il ya quelques semaines
entre temps nous sommes restés fidèles à
la méthode qui qui est la nôtre c'est à
dire travailler avec les acteurs du
secteur du tourisme pour ma part que je
réunis au sein du comité de filière pour
justement envisagé toutes les hypothèses
les différentes phases d'ouverture des
différents lieux sera différent selon
les lieux forcément plus facile quand on
est dans un domaine aérien plutôt que
cloud et ça sera l'occasion et bien de
partager ce travail en
interministérielle autour du président
parlons calendrier justement le 15 mai
c'est le jour envisagé pour la
réouverture de ces lieux le président
avait esquissé cet horizon pour le début
des phases de réouverture maintenant
vous savez c'est la situation sanitaire
qui commande
nous mettons le paquet sur
l'augmentation de la vaccination nous
avons atteint vendredi dernier
500000 injection sur la seule journée de
vendredi et on atteint des rythmes de
croisière qui sont particulièrement
élevées confirmé pas le 15 mai s'est pas
encore will date
vous savez le chef de l'état aura
l'occasion je pense de s'exprimer et
perspectives aujourd'hui ce qui compte
les professionnels d'ailleurs ne demande
pas forcément une date ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est qu'on puisse il a donc
pas immédiatement il souhaite qu'on
puisse les prévenir
deux à trois semaines en amont
naturellement va pouvoir se réorganiser
pour pouvoir préparer la reprise
mais ce qu'il souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse travailler ensemble les
protocoles les conditions de la reprise
c'est faute écoles et centres ajustement
des professionnels question qui se sont
préparé très sérieusement ils nous ont
fait des propositions je peux en
attester
et puis il ya des protocoles qui
entraîneront aussi peut-être des pertes
de recettes de chiffre d'affaires ici
pourquoi on maintiendra nos dispositifs
d'aidé de soutien et on va pas les
débrancher d'un coup d'un seul il est
important que l'état qui a toujours été
là on en est à 26 milliards d'euros mais
des soutiens dans le secteur du tourisme
continue à l'être parce que la reprise
ne se fera que si ce que vous ne dites
monsieur le ministre c'est que pour le
15 mai les protocoles sont déjà prêts
pour le 15 mai les professionnels se
sont préparés sérieusement un des points
que de gaulle ils nous ont fait des
propositions
nous y travaillons au sein du cic la
cellule interministérielle de crise et
voyez c'est ce travail demain qui va se
poursuivre au niveau du chef de l'état
vous comprenez que tout ne peut pas être
la boutique pas tout vous annoncer
aujourd'hui et pour cause on travaille
on est à la tâche mais c'est le message
qu'on envoie aux français c'est que on
se prépare à ce moment là on sait qu'on
a encore quelques semaines où il faut se
serrer les coudes se serrer les dents
parce que le pic n'est pas encore
atteint mais on va y arriver
pour goûter cela je suis dernière
question on a appris que le gouvernement
présentera lundi des mesures plus
contraignantes pour les pays les plus
touchés par l'épidémie un peu à l'image
de ce qui se fait actuellement avec le
brésil quel pays vous avez en tête
alors justement le travail là aussi
ce fait le président d'un public a
souhaité qu'il puisse être abouti
justement pour ce week-end pour lundi
parce que le brésil n'est pas le seul
pays dans le monde qui connaît et bien
une situation sanitaire préoccupant
alors les donc et donc c'est un travail
qui se fait justement au regard des
critères épidémie donc je ne peux pas
vous donner la réponse là c'est un
travail en cours ce que je veux dire
c'est que on a pris cette mesure de
précaution de suspension des vols pour
quelques jours comme nous l'avions fait
en décembre à l'égard du royaume uni
quand pendant 48 heures et bien les
variants ont été annoncés et bien
naturellement on a pris cette mesure
avant jugement de définir un protocole
pour le retour des personnes qui
viennent de ces zones là pour s'assurer
bien que les plus grandes précautions
soient prises et naturellement je veux
avec tara français établis hors de
france est établie au brésil auront la
faculté de revenir cet endroit ce droit
là nous l'assurons quoi qu'il en soit
vous travaillez sur déclare antenne
obligatoires alors bien sûr les tests
pcr
une période d'isolement et donc tout
cela nous sommes en train d'y travailler
et ce que le chef de l'état souhaite
également c'est qu'on puisse travailler
en européen et donc lorsque nous aurons
défini notre propre schéma modèle nous
allons le partage et aussi avec les
autres états membres de l'union
européenne pour essayer de converger
vers des dispositifs qui sont identiques
pour qu'il soit efficace le plus
efficace possible
merci d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup
steve et dans onze minutes très pc très
précisément vous suivrez en direct sur
public sénat le discours de jean castex
suivie d'un débat sur l'organisation des
élections régionales et départementales
des élections maintenu en jambes et avec
un report d'une semaine et pour en
parler on va retourner en salle des
conférences du sénat
steve qui à son micro marc fesneau le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
oui marc fesneau bonjour dans quelques
minutes donc va débuter ce débat l'image
de ce qui s'est fait hier à l'assemblée
nationale
vous vous craignez ce débat où vous
pensez que vous allez être reçus
vous allez bien accueillis comme vous
l'avez été hier l'assemblée nationale il
yad'abord ya jamais atteints d'un débat
en démocratie quand on vote peut-être on
craint pas non plus un vote non
démocratique par ailleurs effectivement
vous l'avais dit à l'assemblée nationale
chacun puisse exprimer hier à la suite
d'un processus qui a été méthodiquement
suivi par le gouvernement est voulue par
le premier ministre et le président de
la république et donc le débat s'est
bien passé à l'assemblée nationale les
parlementaires se sont exprimés les
députés en l'occurrence les sénateurs
s'expriment en cet après-midi ce que je
crois important désormais gouvernement a
donné sa position qui était celle
d'ailleurs qui avait été exprimée je le
rappelle le premier à vide parfois
ministre qui était celle d'un président
principe est d'un postulat c'était de
faire en sorte que nous mettions sur la
table l'idée de voter en juin et donc
c'est bien que chacun puisse exprimer
ses convictions ses inquiétudes ses
doutes et qu'au fond nous sentions tous
responsables d'une chose c'est que les
choses se passent dans les meilleures
conditions possibles que le déroulé de
campagne se passe dans les meilleures
conditions possibles parce qu'une
démocratie confiné si une démocratie on
peut pas exprimer ses idées et par
ailleurs que les citoyens et ont vu la
vive opposition seront réunis à ce que
les citoyens où vont aller voter cette
dernière semaine de juin gilsoul avant
les vacances d'été s'est excusé moi j'ai
des enfants je pense que certains
devraient regarder d'ailleurs les
calendriers scolaires moi mes enfants ne
partent pas avant la fin du calendrier
scolaire 6 juillet à d'abstention les
vacances scolaires sont le 6 juillet je
vous invite d'ailleurs à regarder
compris bison futé vous verrez n'y a pas
de trafic
le week-end du 26 au 27 ans pour dire à
voter mais il faut qu'il faut que ceux
qui s'expriment comme ça on regarde la
réalité de la vie des gens voyez ce
serait plus clair moi la vie que je
connais la vie des gens c'est pas de
partir en vacances le 23 juin c'est
plutôt juillet août et donc ya pas plus
de risques le 25 juin
que la semaine d'avant le 27 juin que la
semaine d'avant
et donc je trouve que maintenant la
responsabilité tous et pas de regarder
les choses et de dire on va avoir de
l'abstention c'est de faire en sorte que
les uns et les autres et par
l'abstention ou le moins l'abstention
possible parce que quand on aime on aime
la démocratie on aime que les gens
votent et puis s'exprimer c'est bien ça
la volonté qu'il faut qu'on aille max
hénault jean castex a annoncé qu'un
projet de loi va être présenté dans les
prochaines semaines un projet de loi qui
sera consacrée à la crise sanitaire sur
quoi il va porter ce passé les
dispositifs dont on a encore besoin
malheureusement pour les raisons que
chacun sait pour continuer à pouvoir
prendre des mesures qui peuvent être
parfois restrictives reconnaissons le
mais qui permet aussi de ne pas être
dans l'état d'urgence sanitaire est
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt un régime qui
sera un gym type que celui que nous
avons connu d'ailleurs en mai juin
dernier un régime de sortie l'état
d'urgence sanitaire mais vous comprenez
bien qu'on a besoin de pouvoir se doter
encore beauty qui nous permettent dans
tel ou tel endroit dans telle ou telle
situation de pouvoir procéder à un
certain nombre de dispositions de
profiter par exemple
non le confinement général cdh état
d'urgence sanitaire c'est celui qu'on a
vu et donc je vous ai dit précisément
les choses c'est imputant un texte qui
vise à accompagner la sortie de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire mais à nous doter
encore d'outils qui nous permette de
pouvoir dans tel ou tel endroit
géographiquement la vue en mayenne par
exemple
dans ce texte il y aura de la nuit il y
aura des mesures qui sont liées à
l'organisation des élections régionales
plutôt des éléments dont on a besoin
juridiquement et d'un point de vue
législatif qui ne sont pas d'ordre
réglementaire pour faire en sorte qu'on
dirait jeu qu'on améliore à tel ou tel
dispositif le point militants parlera
total 20 27 juin ce sont des dates
définitif ou un cas de force majeure
pourrait nous contraindre à robin heures
l'interdiction majeur par nature c'est
comme dans les contrats d'assurance
c'est un cas de force majeure don majeur
est un cas de force majeure non mais si
vous savez moi je ne navigue pas avec
des certitudes
donc on un cas de force majeure est un
carrefour majeur mais je ne crois pas
qu'ils plein force majeure et donc nous
voterons livré 28 juin le conseil
scientifique recommande quand même que
tous les assesseurs soient vaccinés pour
le jour du vote social 40 que les
actions soient vaccinés nous allons
mettre en situation de faire en sorte
que nous puissions suivre un certain
nombre de recommandations donc c'est pas
encore acté que tous les assesseurs vous
venez vous me dites
le conseil scientifique recommande
ottoman et bien nous allons suivre les
recommandations du concessionnaire aux
ailes et ce que je m'étais mis en oeuvre
voilà je peux pas vous dire mieux
et ce sera donc laissé la disposition la
responsabilité d'un gouvernement c'est
de mettre en oeuvre un certain nombre de
dispositions pour faire en sorte que le
vote se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions si celle-là on fait partie
des premiers nice l'a dit hier il leur
dira s'ils sont pas vaccinés autotests
non absolument absolument tout et vous
avez la réponse aux questions vous poser
mais c'est mieux parce que comme ça on
est plus au caire et au fond où ça on
n'est plus au terrain est l'hôte et donc
oui il faut qu'on fasse attention
moi je suis maire j'ai été maire j'ai
été conçu jaurès conseiller municipal
que les assesseurs les scrutateurs
puisse se faire dans de bonnes
conditions et que ceux qui avaient voté
le fassent de façon tranquille c'est la
moindre des choses et à ce moment là on
aura de la mobilisation est pour moi la
mobilisation c'est l'essentiel
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir répondu à
mes questions
merci beaucoup et steve alors cette
séance de questions d'actualité cet
après midi elle a été en grande partie
consacrée à la vague de gel qui frappe
les cultures française c'est la plus
grande catastrophe agronomique du 21e
siècle en france c'est le ministre de
l'agriculture julien de normandie qu'il
a dit est d'ailleurs ce ministre est
bien il est au micro de steve jourdain
en salle des conférences du sénat
oui je viens de normandie bonjour je
vous ai entendu vous exprimer dans
l'hémicycle à plusieurs reprises lundi
au micro des chaînes parlementaires vous
disiez ne pas avoir encore de chiffre
pour évaluer les dégâts causés par la
vague de froid est ce qu'on a un peu
avancé à ce qu'on a des chiffres
aujourd'hui on sait que au moment où je
vous parle
plusieurs centaines de milliards ou de
milliers d'hectares sont impactés avec
une très grosse inquiétude dans le
secteur de l'arboriculture dans le
secteur de la viticulture
je serai là dans quelques heures dans
l'essonne auprès également des grandes
cultures parce que nous avons par
exemple des cultures comme la betterave
houle comme ça qui sont fortement
impactées la difficulté qu'on a c'est
qu'il ya un nouvel épisode de gel qui
est en train de se passer au moment où
je vous parle et donc l'ampleur des
dégâts on ne pourra la voir de manière
très clair qu'à la suite de ce nouvel
épisode donc
plutôt d'ici la fin de la semaine
courant de la semaine prochaine dans
l'hémicycle dire que vous étiez
favorable à une éventuelle réforme des
assurances agricoles une telle réforme à
ce qu'elle pourra avoir lieu cette année
oui elles ont apprécié en fait pas si
compliqué que cela d'un point de vue
technique cela emporte surtout des
considérations financières très
importantes
pourquoi parce que jusqu'à présent on a
un système de l'assurance récolte qui
repose sur un financement par le monde
agricole
et moi je suis convaincu aujourd'hui que
la limite du système il est lé elle
réside dans le fait que le les risques
on cherche à couvrir ne sont plus
finançables uniquement par le monde
agricole le monde agricole
ils subissent et ses effets du
changement climatique
il subit ces pertes de récoles qui est
la sécheresse y subit ses ravages liés
au gel ou liés à la grêle est pourtant
lui demande de supporter lui même en
finançant la science s'ils veulent à
disposition fait tous les français
contribue par ici frau il faut un
renationaliser il faut un moment ou un
autre
faire entrer la solidarité nationale
dont le financement de ces bars labeouf
je suis n'ont cessé il ya beaucoup de
dispositifs qu'on est en train de
regarder moi je suis pas du tout 1 1
je me suis toujours opposée à quelconque
augmentation d'impôts de taxes
donc c'est pas ça mais c'est des
questions de l'impôt ce nom de ces deux
choix budgétaires de choix d'orientation
d'un certain nombre de financements
heureusement que dans notre pays tout ne
se résume pas d'impôts et taxes
il ya des sénateurs qui demande
notamment de la filière viticole sorte
de grenelle de la viticulture pour faire
un point sur la situation ce que vous
êtes favorable mais moi je suis payé
j'en ai parlé là un instant avec la
sénatrice nathalie delattre notamment
évidemment que je suis toujours à
disposition pour pouvoir échanger et se
projeter quel que soit le nom quel que
soit le type de réunion est ce qu'il ne
faut jamais oublier c'est que dans
l'agriculture on a besoin de tant de
long et on le voit avec ses crises ses
crises elle nous impose de réagir à
court terme de manière très forte et
très réactif mais elle nous oblige aussi
à penser le temps de nous et parfois le
ministère de l'agriculture ou de manière
générale des politiques agricoles ont
oublié cette notion du temps pourtant le
temps c'est essentiel dans l'agriculture
oui pour un grenelle
oui pour toutes ces réunions travail
avec la filière viticole
j'en ai déjà beaucoup et je continuerai
à le faire et ses initiatives me
paraissait très bonne petite dernière
question le sénat beaucoup bossé sur
cette question des assurances de la
réforme des assurances agricoles
pourquoi on n'a pas entendu ce que
disait ce que voulait dire le sénat ces
dernières années mais parce que la
question qui est posée aujourd'hui elle
va plus loin que les différents travaux
déjà effectués
les travaux qui ont déjà été effectués
repose sur comment on peut modifier les
paramètres de l'assurance moi je pense
que il faut aller plus loin et que le
constat aujourd'hui c'est que ça n'est
pas une question de deux paramètres
c'est une question de modèle même s'il
suffisait de changer des paramètres
tombe dans les faits c'est pas une
question de paramètres c'est une
question de modèle conseil c'est sortir
et avoir le courage de dire que ce
modèle assurantiel il ne peut plus
reposer uniquement sur les agriculteurs
ou sur un financement par la politique
agricole commune qui en fait est un
financement des agriculteurs donc c'est
ce modèle même qu'il nous faut changer
merci d'avoir des questions merci
beaucoup et steve pour toutes ces
réactions de ministre on va maintenant
retrouver jean massy et notre streamer
politique qui a commenté sur la
plateforme twitch cette séance de
questions d'actualité
alors jean qu'est ce que t'as communauté
a retenu de ces questions d'actualité et
ben écoute alex comme comme tout le
monde on a vu toutes ces questions sur
l'épisode de gel effectivement les
internautes ont noté qu'il y avait
beaucoup de deux interpellations du
gouvernement et de réponse du
gouvernement sur des mesures d'urgence
tout de suite à apporter au monde
agricole notamment viticulteurs qui
souffre particulièrement les internautes
sont nombreux quand même avoir relevé le
fait qu'il ya assez peu d'interrogations
à la fois de la part des sénateurs et du
gouvernement sur les conséquences du
changement climatique
le dérèglement climatique qui risquent à
l'avenir de répéter ces épisodes de gel
et donc ces calamités agricoles
quelle réflexion de plus long terme est
un peu plus structurelles pour notre
modèle agricole sa a manqué un petit peu
au débat du point de vue d'un certain
nombre d'internautes et puis sinon ils
ont aussi relevé la question de philippe
bas la question de philippe bas qui
s'est émue et visiblement de
l'organisation du conseil des ministres
en visioconférence alors je t'avoue que
là les internautes qui sont nombreux à
7/10 mais on s'en fout un peu en fait
que le gouvernement se réunissent en
vision ou en présentiel
après tout on est en pleine pandémie
voilà donc voilà voilà un peu les
réactions qu'on a vu merci beaucoup
jean pour ce point sur cette séance
commentait sur la plateforme twitch dans
le cadre de ton émission sénat stream
alors c'est la fin de cette page
consacrée aux questions d'actualité mais
restez avec nous car dans quelques
secondes le discours de jean castex au
sénat sur les élections régionales et
départementales va comment va commencer
il sera suivi d'un débat et d'un vote
des sénateurs
pour en parler je vais rejoindre
[Musique]